Zwei Minuten nach 22 Uhr. Was spürst denn du da? Ist das ein alter Mitschnitt? Wo ist denn das? Ein Mikrofon?
Tim?
Ja, aber es war deine Stimme.
Immerhin. Wie weißt du, was das ist? Du kommst hier irgendwie zehn Sekunden von der Sendung. Wo ist das Ziel?
Kann ich was dafür, dass der Obersound beauftragte, hier unser Jingle gelöscht hat? Wir versuchen dann nachher mal anzufangen. Und vier Leute stehen im Studio, Chaosradio 89 auf Fritz, hört ihr? Einen wunderschönen guten Abend im Studio Jens, Frank und Tim. Holger. Und die Musik, die hier läuft, die hat nicht ich ausgesucht, ich wollte das nur mal sagen, weil ich gerade so eine Prinzen-CD in der Hand hab. Das ist mir ein bisschen unangenehm. Siehst du diese kleinen Bläschen, die ich hier am Handballen habe?
Es geht ja auch um Bewusstseinserweiterung.
Achso, es geht um Bewusstseinserweiterung.
Da hab ich in das Dokument für die Auswahl der Musik geschrieben, keine Schnulzen, mit zwei Rausrufezeichen.
Echt? Welches Dokument ist das? War das was auf Tims, was im Fringe war?
Ja, was Tim in irgendeinem Fall gelöscht hat.
Achso.
Im Übrigen ist die Wunschmusikliste von heute, Tim, die bei dir im Blog zu lesen war, genau 23 Titel lang, was ich sehr verdächtig gefunden habe. Glücklicherweise hat unser Archivar nicht alle 23, sondern nur 18 von den Wünschen gefunden.
Oh, es sind fünf übrig.
Genau, so sieht es mal aus. Und dafür aber noch mindestens zehn andere oben draufgepackt, die auch noch Schwassen nicht genug fanden.
Mal gucken, vielleicht kommen ja noch ein paar lustige MP3s rein, eins ist ja heute schon reingekommen.
Tatsache.
Ja, diese schöne Orkutwelt, die werden wir nachher auch noch mal schön sehen.
Schöne Orkutwelt?
Ja, ja, es ist alles ganz toll. Jetzt guck nicht so verdunst.
Ja, nee, ich dachte du...
Wir spielen halt moderne Musik.
Musik zur Zeit, wie man früher so sagte.
Ach so.
Oder wollen wir damit gleich anfangen?
Ja, ich wollte gerade sagen, macht doch eine schöne Orkutwelt.
Dann muss ich mir nun...
Weißt du, was du vergessen hast, Tim? Zu sagen, worum es heute geht.
Ja, weil ich ja dachte, du machst das. Aber ich kann das natürlich gerne tun. Also hallo, hier ist Chaosradio 89. Soweit waren wir schon, wie weit waren wir noch nicht. Wir waren noch nicht so weit, das Thema zu verkünden. Und das Thema wird heute sein Software Social Networks.
Entschuldigung, ich dachte, du hättest das inzwischen ausgemacht.
Ach so, das kann ich gleich tun.
Ich muss jetzt alles hier gleichzeitig sein, dein Gerät aus dem Podslash vom Server.
Also unser Thema sind soziale Netze und soziale Software. Wir wollen dann halt weit erklären, was sich hinter diesen aktuellen Buzzwords versteckt, was man also unter sozialer Software verstehen kann. Und insbesondere wollen wir die Dynamik der jetzt ganz halbmäßig aufkommenden Social Networks analysieren und besprechen. Und vor allem euch auch dazu befragen, inwieweit ihr damit schon Erfahrungen gesammelt habt, ob ihr da lustige Geschichten dazu zu erzählen habt, was ihr dort erlebt habt, was ihr euch davon versprecht und was man vielleicht auch, was sich daraus noch entwickelt, oder ob das alles nur ein dummer Halb ist und man das nächsten Monat schon wieder unter den Teppich der Geschichte kehren muss.
Ja natürlich, aber bis dahin macht es echt Laune, oder?
Bis dahin ist es auf jeden Fall schon recht spaßig gewesen. Mindestens die Auseinandersetzung darüber.
Kann ich jetzt den Knopf wieder drücken?
Ja, wir kümmern uns also weitestgehend jetzt erst mal um Freundschaft. Und weil es um Freundschaft geht, wollen wir das auch musikalisch untermalen. Oder?
Ich dachte, jetzt käme die schöne neue Orkut-Welt.
Ich bin da nicht so weit. Wie soll ich denn reden? Gleich sollte ich nach Dateien suchen.
Du meinst, ich tue ein und ausschalte?
Du hast ein Mac-Multitasking. Okay, okay, okay. Bin ich drauf? Nee, jetzt nicht mehr. Willst du wieder drauf? Nein. Gut, dann machen wir jetzt erst mal ein aus deiner Wishlist. Das ist nicht meiner. Das ist nicht von mir. Sag doch nein!
Nein, nein, da hat sie kein Wort!
Ja Hintergrundmusik raus.
Hintergrundmusik raus?
Funny Fandannen, Freunde der Realität, Motto-Musik, Gleichsam im Chaosradio 89, denn es geht um Freunde, beziehungsweise Soziales, was ja auch mit Freunden ist, also Social Networking, wo Freunde bei rumkommen. Das kann man auch einfacher ausdrücken, aber warum?
Warum was?
Weiß ich nicht, willst du drauf?
Wo drauf?
Ja hier.
Achso, ja, jetzt muss ich schon wieder zwei Sachen gleichzeitig machen.
Frank, sag du doch auch mal was.
Wir können vielleicht mal kurz erklären, was...
Du bist doch gar nicht Frank.
Nee, ich bin nicht Frank, aber...
Du kannst in einem alle auf der Nase.
Holger, vielleicht können wir kurz erklären, was Social Software und Social Networking eigentlich ist, weil das haben wir bis jetzt noch nicht getan.
Mach doch mal.
Ja, also früher gabs mal Communities. Und früher hat man auch gedacht, damit könnte man Geld im Internet verdienen. Aber naja, das hat halt irgendwie nicht ganz geklappt. Social Networking oder Social Software ist eigentlich alles das, wo ich mich irgendwie persönlich einbringe und dann irgendwie versuche, auch mein soziales Geflecht irgendwie auf das Netzwerk abzubilden. Das klingt erstmal sehr abstrakt, aber die Anwendungen von Social Software kennt eigentlich jeder. Das ist immer, wenn man sich mit einer Gruppe von Freunden oder mit einer Gruppe von Leuten, die man nicht kennt, aber mit denen man irgendwas gemeinsam hat, sich gemeinsam im Netz austobt und dann vielleicht gemeinsam ein Dokument erstellt in einem Wiki oder intertextuell sich austauscht, zum Beispiel in einem Webblog oder in einem Chat oder zum Beispiel in einer Plattform, wo man dann halt Freundschaftsverbindungen auch grafisch visualisieren kann. Zum Beispiel in Orkut.
Also im Kern geht es einfach um Software, die die Person in den Mittelpunkt stellt und nicht irgendetwas anderes. Und das soziale Geflecht der Verbindung unter uns besonders betont.
Das Hintergrundmusik?
Das ist die Hintergrundmusik.
Soll ich jetzt noch mal ein Lied mit Freund singen?
Nein, das ist die default Hintergrundmusik.
Das ist das, was in der iTunes immer oben kommt, wenn man irgendwie... Communities ist ja so ein relativ abstrakter Begriff, worum es dabei ging, war der Versuch, Geld damit zu verdienen, dass Leute auf der Webseite rumhängen. Also man hat halt eine Webseite kreiert, von der man dachte, die könnte irgendwie interessant sein und dann dachte man sich...
Da gab es immer dieses riesengroße Ding.
Genau, Boo war irgendwie der...
Boo war doch auch so ein Community.
Nee, Boo war der Klamottenladen.
Ach stimmt, Boo war von...
Vor dem hab ich noch einen riesengroßen Pappkarton. Boo-Boot gab es doch noch.
Jedenfalls hat jeder, der irgendwie irgendwas... Ich glaube, Web.de war auch mal eine Community. Irgendwann war Community, dort wird man von den Venture-Kapitalisten Geld bekommen hat. Aber zum Glück hat dieser Zeitlauf dann auch geändert. Das war nur ein Jahr oder eineinhalb. Aber Community war halt mal ganz... Die Idee war halt, Leute kommunizieren nicht miteinander. Also sollen sie doch einfach im Internet miteinander kommunizieren. Also hängen sie auf der Webseite rum. Und je bunter, schöner und toller die Webseite ist, desto häufiger und länger werden sie darauf rumhängen. Und Leute, die auf einer Webseite rumhängen, sind ja sozusagen potentielle Werbekunden. Also kam man mit Werbung, die man auf einer Community schaltet, Geld verdient. Das war sozusagen der erste Anlauf, der halt grandios gegen den Baum gefahren ist.
Dummerweise war die Werbung in der Community immer für andere Communities, die dann wiederum Werbung für die Erste gemacht haben, oder?
Das waren die letzten Zuckungen, kurz vor Schluss sozusagen. Da war da nicht mehr viel.
Aber hat gut funktioniert. Prima Partys.
Genau, es gab ein paar schöne Partys. Der nächste Schritt, den wir jetzt sehen danach, werden halt diese Social-Network-Software-Sachen sein. Da werden wir noch ein bisschen näher drauf eingehen später. Vielleicht gehen wir noch mal einen Schritt davor, so vor den Communities. Da gab es ja sozusagen auch schon Internet und Mailbox-Netze und ähnliche Dinge. Und eigentlich, worum es immer ging, war so ein bisschen Closed User Group, Kuschelfeeling. Ich hab meine Peer-Group im Netz, ich hab irgendwie meine Freundin da, ich bin unter Leuten, die ich kenne, mit denen ich was zu tun habe. Leute, die neu dazu kommen, sind halt auch Leute, mit denen ich wahrscheinlich was zu tun haben will, weil die kennen ja meine Freunde und die sind zumindest so ähnlich wie ich und vielleicht nicht wesentlich dummer als meine Freunde oder ähnliche Dinge. Und ganz am Anfang, als die Mailbox-Netze noch jung waren, das war das ja durchaus so Back then, so Cerberus und noch früher und so, Fido, da war das ja tatsächlich so, da gab es halt so diese Gruppen, in denen man sich ausgetauscht hat und es gab halt thematisch organisierte Gruppen und auch einfach nur so Laborgruppen. Und irgendwann, nachdem das Internet dann kam und diese Massen da rein strömten und es einfach irgendwie nur noch sozusagen so, als hätte man die Tür aufgeschlossen und da draußen stehen zwei Millionen Leute, sind diese ganzen Gruppen evaporiert. Da gab es dann nur noch Private Mailingists, in denen man sich austauschte. Heutzutage, wenn man ins Usenet geht, ist es eigentlich nur noch West Trading. Im Usenet gibt es noch ganz wenige News Groups, die halt irgendeine Art von Family Community Feeling haben. Die meisten sind halt einfach nur noch so Labaforen oder West Trading Gruppen.
Das ist ein richtiges Opfer des Massenansturms.
Es scheint Communities zu geben, die skalieren nicht. Also die einfach durch die Größe, wie das Usenet zum Beispiel, dann gibt es dann Barbareneinfälle, dann geht die Kultur den Bach runter, dann gibt es entweder nur Polizeiansätze an allen Ecken und Enden oder die Leute verschwinden halt einfach. Oder es gibt Communities, die werden erst dann interessant, wenn sie richtig groß werden. Also eBay ist so ein Beispiel. eBay war richtig uninteressant, als da halt nur ein paar hundert Leute drin waren. Und richtig benutzt haben wir das alle erst als so Tausende von Menschen auf eBay.
Klar, aber ist Community der richtige Begriff, um eBay zu beschreiben?
eBay nennt sich halt immer Community. Eigentlich finde ich Community als ein wenig abwertendes Wort für eBay schon ganz okay. Community ist mittlerweile ein echt verschlissener Begriff, den man für eBay durchaus problemlos verwenden kann, ohne runter beim Gesicht zu werden. Und wohingegen diese neueren Sachen, die so langsam aufkommen, die so wirklich ein bisschen mehr Family, ein bisschen mehr Cushel-Feeling sind, wo man halt wirklich nur innerhalb seiner Peer-Group ist und nicht irgendjemanden versucht, mit der großen Marketing-Qualität herzukommen, da würde ich nicht Community zu sein. Das passt irgendwie nicht zu ordentlich.
Social Software halt einfach.
Ja, Social Software ist schlecht. Besser. Na ja. Sagen wir mal, so ganz früher, als es nur noch wenige, also erst wenige Leute gab es, weil ich erinnere mich so an das Gefühl, so zum ersten Mal in eine Mailbox, und dann gab es ja noch so 20 andere Leute auf dieser Mailbox, die schon 100 User im Undernet, unter 10.000 im Irgnet. Als man sich noch so kannte, so hat man sich in so eine Mailbox eingewählt und dann war man so in der Stadt, in der Stadt waren wahrscheinlich auch so Leute, die irgendwie so ein bisschen selber so drauf waren, wie man selbst. Sonst wären sie wohl nicht in dieser Mailbox gelandet. Und dann hat man sich mal in einer anderen Stadt in die Mailbox eingewählt und guckt, was da so los ist. Ja, das war schon interessant. Aber damals war es halt wirklich alles noch so klein, mini, paar Leute, die Leute waren meistens nicht scheiße drauf, außer manchmal.
Und man hat sie vorher schon gekannt. Oder bei den größten Teils.
Nein, das war interessant. Bei den Mailboxnetzen war der Kennenlernfaktor relativ wichtig. Dass ich viele Leute kennengelernt habe, die ich sonst nie getroffen hätte. Was dann später im Internet eigentlich kaum der Fall war. Also da lernt man schon mal jemanden im Internet kennen. Passiert zwar, aber es ist seltener als sonst.
Das hat natürlich auch ein bisschen was damit zu tun, wie man selber in dem realen Leben mit Kommunikation am Start ist. Ich glaube, dass gerade die neuen Social Networks, die jetzt aufkommen, insbesondere den Leuten mal wieder eine neue Tür aufmachen, die es ebenso mit der Kommunikation im Wahnleben nicht so haben, aus welchen Gründen das auch immer ist. Das kann zum Beispiel auch allein schon was mit dem Wohnort zu tun haben. Wenn man halt irgendwie hinter Tupfingen, hinterm Wald wohnt und man hat da normalerweise eine Community von 62 Dorfbewohnern, dann ist natürlich klar, dass es einen dann schon ein bisschen mehr ins Internet wirft, weil man dann natürlich sehr viel kürzeren Zugang hat. Auch diese Kontaktbörsen, die jetzt halt hochkommen, sowas wie Neu.de und so.
Das ist ja nicht erst seit jetzt.
Das ist nichts Neues.
Neu.de hab ich mir noch gar nicht. Ist das sowas wie Friend Scout 24?
Es gibt jetzt drei Millionen Partnersuch-Communities im Netz, von denen wahrscheinlich 98 Prozent wieder grandios gegen die Wand fahren werden. Aber der Trend ist offensichtlich, die Leute wollen wieder ein bisschen mehr Kuschel im Internet, die wollen einfach nicht mehr zu drei Millionen Leuten reden, weil mit drei Millionen Leuten kann man nicht reden, sondern man kann höchstens drei Millionen Leute anbrüllen. Mehr kann man nicht tun.
Deswegen ist das, was Tim eben meinte, auch nur so halb richtig. Also so ein Dorf mit 62 Leuten ist schon eine tolle Community. Aber ich will mir halt mein Dorf aussuchen und dann nur 62 coole Einwohner in diesem Dorf haben. Und das kann ich jetzt halt so langsam hier aufbauen im Netz.
Bis man vor die Tür geht.
Ja.
Ich war ja schon immer für eine coole deutsche Musik im bundesdeutschen Tonrundfunk. Die Prinzen, mein bester Freund, auf Wunsch von Tim Prittler. Sicher.
Du hast dir das ausgesucht.
Pass mal auf.
Ich kann das nachweisen.
Das ist alles total demokratisch und zusammengetragen worden von der Community, die jetzt hier um Chaosradio herum entstanden ist.
Danke.
Da sieht man ja auch, dass jeder so seinen eigenen Blick drauf hat, wie das so, was eigentlich ein Freund ist, so nicht. Da gibt es ja auch gerade in diesem, ja, in dem Thema, wo wir sowieso draufkommen werden, also Orkut, eins der meistgehypten und meistbesprochenen Social Networks, die derzeit da sind, da gibt es halt auch so dieses Modell von wer ist wessen Freund. Und es wird natürlich das Wort Friend benutzt, nur dass man natürlich das Wort Friend im Englischen auch genauso gut als Bekannter auslegen kann. Im deutschsprachigen Raum führt das dann zu einigen Konfusionen.
Ja, ich habe jetzt mittlerweile irgendwie vier Leute als Friend bezeichnet und habe jetzt selber 12.000 oder irgendwas absurdes, kann das angehen?
Du bist zu 12.000 Leuten verbunden über diese Leute. Ach, das war das. Genau. Aber die Schwierigkeit ist tatsächlich, Friend ist halt genau wie... Es gibt im Deutschen ja auch keine Unterscheidung zwischen Safety und Security.
Es gibt nur Sicherheit.
Es gibt halt nur Sicherheit. Im Englischen gibt es halt immer noch ein paar mehr Ausdifferenzen. Im Deutschen gibt es für andere Sachen mehr Ausdifferenzen als im Englischen. Aber Friend ist halt genauso ein klassisches Beispiel. Friend ist halt... Da gibt es halt noch sicherlich irgendwie Bekannter. Und irgendwie den kenne ich auch noch. Den habe ich mal auf einer Party gesehen. Diese Ausdifferenz fehlt halt.
Das ist aber irgendwie einfach ein Vokabelproblem. Also das kann man auch auf Dict Leo Org nachschlagen. Das ist bekannter ist die erste angegebene Bedeutung von Friend im Englischen.
Tatsächlich, bekannter ist die erste angegebene Bedeutung.
Das ist ja ein Ding, übrigens Orkut.
Die duzen sich ja auch alle da im Englischen.
Wer sich Orkut mal angucken will, eine www.orkut.de.com, aber das wird mir nicht helfen, weil Orkut ja ein Invitation Only System ist, wie es so schön heißt.
Das heißt, man kommt da nur rein, wenn man von jemand anderen eingeladen wird.
Warum steht denn dann unten rechts Sign Up oder sowas ähnliches?
Ja, dann bekommst du genau den Text. Das ist ein Invitation Only System.
Ich hab da noch nie drauf geklickt, weil ich das mit tollen Leuten nenne. Also der Sign Up funktioniert, indem du halt irgendwie in deiner Umgebung fahrend ist, ob irgendjemand schon drin ist. Das hat viral ganz gut funktioniert. Orkut gehört jetzt auch zu den Systemen, die jetzt gerade in der Nerd-Szene mehr Interesse geweckt haben, was schlicht und ergreifend an der Tatsache lag, dass eben hinter diesem Projekt zumindest partiell Google steckt. Orkut ist nämlich nicht nur der Name dieses Systems, sondern auch der Name des Programmierers dieses Systems.
Der Vorname?
Der Vorname, der Nachname, den hat er Gott sei Dank nicht genommen. Der wäre dann unaussprechlich, wäre es bestimmt kein Erfolg gewesen. Daher heißt es so, und das ist aber im Prinzip zumindest die aktuelle Legende. Eins dieser Freizeitprojekte, Google Mitarbeiter haben einen Tag in der Woche frei oder werden geradezu dazu angehalten, ihr eigenes Ding zu machen. Und da hat er wohl das geboren. Da haben sie sich jetzt wohl gerade gedacht, naja, das unterstützen wir mal so ein bisschen und gucken mal, was passiert. Also von daher ist Orkut eigentlich derzeit auch eher so ein Experimentierfeld.
Achso, ich dachte, das diente irgendwie Google dann dazu, auch mal ihre User ein bisschen besser kennenzulernen.
Da können wir gleich mal drüber diskutieren, was da eigentlich der Hintergrund ist.
Da werden wir das doch tun. Aber erstmal mal Grisha, Grisha, können wir Nachrichten machen oder?
Wir können nicht, ich muss hier ein bisschen umbauen.
Ja, nee, ich frag ja nur.
Deine Kollegen haben ja so viel mitgebracht, irgendwie das ganze Studio.
Das sind nicht meine Kollegen, das sind meine Friends.
Deine Kollegen. Denn 14 über 2, dann 100, 1.
Ja wunderbar, hier nochmal vorwärts und zurück, hier beim Kulturradio Nummer 1, Chaosradio 89. Vorwärts, rückwärts und die Damen. Und nochmal ein paar Chaoslose hier.
Ich muss euch jeder so anmerken, dass ich mich vor dieser Musik distanziere. Also ich weiß nicht, wie die auf diese Playlist gekommen ist, aber...
Tim hat gesagt, äh...
Okay, wir stellen fest, Tim ist verantwortlich.
Gut, wir haben einen Hörerhörer. Tim hatte darum gebeten, Musik in denen das Wort Freunde vorkommt.
Und ihr geht dann einfach hin und weht blind alles aus, was Freunde im Team hat?
Ja, natürlich. Was denkst du denn? Hier ist es übrigens, das Chaosradio 89. Nein, wir haben jetzt gerade niemanden am Telefon.
Wie der Hörer hat verschreckt aufgelegt. Ab jetzt wird die Musik auch besser, da bin ich mir ganz sicher.
Du könntest zum Beispiel die Hintergrundgesichter einschalten.
Cd's zur Zensur bitte.
Ich hatte noch was von Johnny Hill.
Ist okay.
Also Cuddy and Wester machen wir aber.
Irgendwie wird er kein deutscher Schlager mehr.
Ich kann ja noch mal ein bisschen was zu dem sagen, was wir noch nicht gesagt haben. Also Social Software, was ja bei uns am Anfang stand, da gibt es ja schon eine ganze Menge. Wir hatten ja neulich schon mal eine Sendung über Webblogs. Das gehört auf jeden Fall auch dazu, weil das eine sehr persönliche Kommunikation ist. Aber da ist man ja im Prinzip sein eigener Sender.
Obwohl es auch da irgendwie einen sozialen Text gibt über diese Trackbacks und über Kommentare und so entsteht auch schon...
Und die Blogroll zum Beispiel, die man explizit die Leute auch verlinkt, was man selber noch liest. Und wir hatten das auch mit dem Live Journal, wo es auch diese geschlossenen Webblog-Systeme gibt, wo man also genau kontrollieren darf, wer eigentlich das eigene Webblog lesen kann und untereinander pflegen halt alle ihre eigenen Webblogs. Und werden da natürlich auch sehr viel privater, als sie das jetzt auf einer öffentlich lesbaren Webblog-Seite sein würden. Setze ich mal so voraus. Zumindest hat man das bei einem Mädchen was angerufen hat und davon so berichtet hat, dass sie das so pflegt. Und das ebenso auch als Ergänzung ihrer Kommunikation sieht. Und so ist das glaube ich auch mit diesen Social Networks, die jetzt dazukommen, dass es halt einfach mal wieder eine neue Spielvariante ist. So einen produktiven Bereich sind natürlich Wikis schon ziemlich lange aktiv und werden auch gerade so in der letzten Zeit sehr viel populärer. Auch im Bereich Softwareentwicklung, wo neue Protokolle, Formate gemeinsam so entwickelt werden. Wiki ist ja ein System, wo man jede Seite modifizieren kann. Man kann also direkt sagen, ich möchte hier was hinzufügen und dann da reinschreiben.
Wir haben übrigens auch das Problem, was ich immer beim Wiki sehe oder mutmaße, ist, dass da wieder Kreti und Pleti irgendeinen Scheißdreck reinschreiben. Also genau das selbe Problem, das wir im Birknet mal hatten.
Ja, aber es hat sich gezeigt, dass es trotzdem funktioniert. Weil in einem Wiki, wenn einer Scheiße reinschreibt, dann ist der nächste auch gleich wieder da und nimmt es wieder raus. Ein Wiki hat in der Regel auch so eine Versionskontrolle. Das heißt, man kann Änderungen auch rückgängig machen, direkt aus der Datenbank heraus. Beziehungsweise es ändert sich einfach dadurch, dass es jemand einfach rausnimmt, der möchte, dass da was Sinnvolles drinsteht. Und davon abgesehen, dieses Troll-Verhalten mit reinschreien, das funktioniert ja eigentlich auch immer nur, wenn man das Gefühl hat, es hört auch jemand zu. Und das ist natürlich auf Tausenden von Wikis dann einfach... Es ist einfach nicht interessant, das zu machen, weil es verschwindet dann sowieso nach einiger Zeit. Es regt sich so direkt keiner auf. Also es ist nicht so eine Kampfkultur, wie man das in Chats oder auf Mailinglisten findet. Und von daher sind Wikis da doch ziemlich effizient.
Wobei das natürlich richtig ist. Also für ganz viele Bereiche von diesem Social-Software-Zeug haben wir noch überhaupt keine Regel. Da sind wir gerade dabei, so die Regel ein bisschen zu finden und zu gucken, wie so ein Miteinander funktionieren kann. Und das, worauf immer alle als erstes kommen, ist irgendwie das Sozialgeflecht kaputt zu machen. Das fällt immer jedem als ersten ein.
Ja, so das Simpelste.
Genau, das ist das Simpelste. Und wenn diese Phase dann mal überwunden ist, dann kann halt was Spannendes passieren. Und ich glaube, wir sind jetzt so in der Phase, wo es anfängt spannend zu werden.
Also ganz am Anfang, als das Usenet noch groß war und im Prinzip so das größte soziale System, jeder konnte in öffentliche Foren posten. Das ist auch tot, oder?
Also ich hab so das Gefühl, als...
Na, es ist halt überrollt worden. Wir hatten das ja eben schon erwähnt. Es ist einfach überrollt worden von zu vielen Leuten, die die Regeln zu wenig kennen. Weil man muss natürlich sich eine Weile erstmal mit so einem System beschäftigen, um die Dynamik, die dahinter steht, zu verstehen und den Nutzen für sich selber rauszuziehen. Das ist im Usenet halt doppelt schwierig, weil es nicht so einfach zu benutzen ist. Die Software ist bei Lybe jetzt nicht so einfach und ausgereift, wie das jetzt mit Webbrausen usw. ist. Und es hatte sich ja schon sehr früh im frühen Internet, bevor das überhaupt irgendwie populär war, gab es schon diese Netiquette, wo er drin steht, irgendwie liest er erstmal was anderes durch, bevor er anfängt zu schreiben und solche Sachen. Wenn man das befolgt hat, dann ging das eigentlich auch ganz gut, aber die Netiquette ist im Usenet zumindest komplett unter die Räder gekommen. Auch wegen Spam.
Eine Community, die nicht skaliert hat einfach, so von der Größe her.
Das war halt...
Ich bin vielleicht ein entschuldigendem Idiot, aber was genau heißt skaliert?
Für viele Leute tauglich sein.
Was für fünf Leute funktioniert, muss nicht für 5000 funktionieren.
Verstehe, okay.
Wenn etwas skaliert, dann hat es eben diese Eigenschaft, dass es eben bis zu einem bestimmten Wachstumsgrad eben auch mithalten kann.
Die Mechanismen im Usenet waren halt sehr simpel. Man hat eigentlich, genau auch wie in den Mailingnissen damals, beziehungsweise in den Newsgroups, einen gewissen Kreis von Leuten gehabt, die man kannte, von denen wusste man, da lohnt es sich, den Beitrag zu lesen. Die haben in der Regel sinnvolles Zeug geschrieben. Dann gab es halt die üblichen Trottel, die halt irgendwelchen Unsinn geschrieben haben, die hatten wir halt ignoriert. Und das System funktionierte halt, solange es halt eine überschaubare Anzahl von Usern war. Also wenn man halt einfach nur ein paar hundert Leute im Überblick behalten muss, von denen man weiß, wer was taugt, wer was nicht taugt, kann man das noch im Kopf tun. Ab einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt geht es halt nicht mehr, weil es zu viele Leute sind. Und halt einfach, wenn der Rauschfaktor, also zu viele Trottel da drin sind, funktioniert es halt nicht mehr. Und genau dieser, das Usenet hat halt, wie gesagt, bei so ein paar hundert Leuten pro Newsgroup einfach geendet.
Ab da ging es halt nicht mehr.
Und wenn man sich so anguckt, die funktionierenden Mailinglisten, die es heute noch gibt, die haben auch alle immer nur so zwei, dreihundert Leute maximal. Und nicht mehr. Wenn es mehr werden, steigt der Rauschfaktor wieder zu stark an, weil dann die Kontrollfaktoren versagen. Weil dann macht man sich nicht mehr die Mühe festzustellen, wer taugt nun was, wer taugt nichts und so weiter und so fort.
Ja oder die Regeln ändern sich. Also man setzt dann ganz knallhart auf Moderation und sagt dann halt irgendwie, okay wir haben ja 1000 Leute und nur das, was der Moderator, der Gottkaiser dieser Community halt durchlässt, das wird dann halt auch irgendwie auf die Liste gesetzt.
Ja und was wir jetzt halt sehen, diese neuen Social Software Systeme, die jetzt kommen, die sind wiederum eigentlich ein Versuch, Kommunikation im Internet wieder in, sagen wir mal, Closed User Groups, die sich von selbst finden, die halt entweder thematisch oder nach Freundeskreisen orientiert sind, aufzubauen und halt diese Regeln für soziale Kontrolle möglich zu machen. Soziale Kontrolle funktioniert ja eigentlich nie mit den Polizisten. Das heißt irgendwie moderating ist halt extrem anstrengend oder wenn man halt irgendwie versucht, nach Stichworten zu filtern, was auch immer die Leute versuchen, es funktioniert alles nicht, es funktioniert eigentlich nur, dass man Leute ein Stück weit aus der kompletten Anonymität reißt, also dass sozusagen es klar ist, dass jemand jemand ist, der mit dem und dem im Zusammenhang steht und halt einen gewissen, es einen gewissen sozialen Kontext gibt, an dem man jemand einschätzen kann. Das wiederum ist die erste Voraussetzung dafür, dass sich soziale Regeln rausbilden. Und ich bin da ganz gespannt. Die Sachen, die es momentan gibt, die taugen dafür noch nicht wirklich sehr. Da werden wir noch in Detail drauf kommen. Aber ich denke, da...
Das was auch völlig neu ist im Moment, also bisher diese Social-Software-Geschichten haben sich immer an anderen Medien orientiert. Also die Weblogs und Instant Messaging, das waren so Sachen, die orientierten sich an Nachrichten. Da ging das über die Nachricht, das soziale Netzwerk. Bei dem Wiki war das Ganze dokumentenbasiert. Man arbeitete gemeinsam an einem Dokument. Also bei Wikipedia funktioniert es ja hervorragend. Da gibt es eine Community, die an einem großen Dokument arbeitet.
Das große Dokument ist der Versuch, das größte Lexikon der Welt zu schreiben.
Ganz genau.
Es ist schon interessant, wie oft man zum Beispiel bei Wikipedia-Anträge trifft, von bei Google nach unten einen Begriff sucht, der ein bisschen ausgefallen ist.
Mittlerweile suche ich sogar bei Wikipedia zuerst und werde fast immer fündig. Das mag an meinem beschränkten Geist nie.
Das ist ein erfolgreiches Beispiel für eine funktionierende Software.
Bevor wir es vergessen, wir haben jetzt hier für diese Radiosendung auch einen Realtime-Wiki sozusagen im Betrieb. Das kann leider jetzt nur von Macintosh-Benutzern.
Ja, dann kümmere ich mich weiter um die Knöpfe hier.
Das heißt, es ist aber ein sehr schönes Programm. Heißt Sub-Ether-Edit. Ist von einer Gruppe von Freaks aus München programmiert worden und ist im Prinzip ein normaler Texteditor mit der Möglichkeit, dass man sich über das Netz damit verbinden kann. Wenn ihr auf die Chaosradio-Homepage chaosradioccc.de geht, dann findet ihr dort den Link. Wenn ihr dieses Programm installiert habt, könnt ihr den einfach anklicken, dann kommt das Dokument hoch und da sammeln wir hier auch gerade Feedback. Das ist im Prinzip auch wie ein Wiki. Jeder kann irgendwie alles schreiben und löschen und hier sammeln sich eben auch gerade Hinweise und Texte und sind schon irgendwie sechs Leute.
Und um die Klammer nochmal zuzumachen, es ist nicht mehr nachrichtenbasiert, wie bei Weblogs und Instant Messaging. Es ist nicht mehr Dokumenten zentriert, wie bei Wikis oder wie bei diesem Sub-Ether-Edit, sondern das Neue an diesen Social-Networking-Geschichten ist halt, es ist plötzlich Freundeskreis oder Sozialgeflechts orientiert. Und daran orientiert sich dann halt die Kommunikation oder das, was ich irgendwie aus dem großen Internet rausfühtete. Wir hatten eben schon gesagt, okay, ich kann im Internet mit drei Millionen Menschen kommunizieren, aber wer will schon mit drei Millionen Menschen kommunizieren?
Nee, nicht kommunizieren, du kannst drei Millionen Menschen anbrüllen. Genau, anbrüllen.
Morrissey, hold on to your friends hier at Chaosradio 89. Es geht um Social Networking. Eben haben wir behauptet, das Usenet sei tot. Und der Michael, guten Abend.
Ja, hi, der Kio hier übrigens. Man wollte, man meinte, ich müsste einen richtigen Namen angeben.
Ja, natürlich. Michael.
Ja, ich hab, man, es ließ dich nicht ganz überhören, dass ihr einen etwas pessimistischen Eindruck über die aktuelle Lage des Usenets habt.
Du darfst das gerne differenzierter betrachten.
Ja klar, also ich meine, ich kann jetzt nur fürs deutsche Usenet reden. Also das sind das vor allem also die großen Gruppen, also das Internationale, das ist schon ein bisschen chaotischer. Das Deutsche ist eigentlich momentan relativ gut, weil es gab vor allem so ein bisschen in den letzten Jahren so nötige Gruppenreformation, Umsortierungen, Gruppen sind kleiner geworden, wodurch sich eigentlich im Prinzip da schon jetzt wieder mehr so soziale Netzwerke, wenn wir denn beim Begriff bleiben wollen, gebildet haben. Weil in den etwas kleineren Gruppen, die fachspezifisch sind, dann stellt es sich da oft schon relativ oft heraus, dass es ein paar Leute sind, die die Gruppe führen und die da im Prinzip Sagen haben und Leute, die sich drumherum scharen. Und es funktioniert eigentlich mittlerweile doch relativ okay. Und Dolce U's Net ist eigentlich in vielen Gruppen derzeit sehr lesbar.
Was würdest du da mal so als Beispielhaft herauspicken an Foren?
Ja gut, es gibt Gruppen, die ich so lese, so Diski, Elektronik, also was ich für Elektronikbasteleien beschäftigt, was sich auch recht gut liest, ist D-Sock Drogen. So wenn man sich dann mit dem Thema im weitesten Sinne beschäftigt. Ja, das sind so meine Hauptfavoriten. Dann gibt es noch ganz viele andere Gruppen. Ich meine, ich kenne auch nicht alle Gruppen. Es kommt auch darauf an, wofür man sich interessiert. Aber ich habe auch gehört, dass zum Beispiel die PHP-Gruppe sehr gut sein soll, mit einem sehr sachlichen Ton und wenig Geflame und so habe ich selber nicht gelesen, ob das zugetragen worden ist. Es gibt doch einige oder recht recht viele gute Gruppen, muss man halt mal gucken.
Wie ist denn so die Spam-Problematik im Griff bekommen worden, deiner Auffassung nach?
Ja, das klappt eigentlich relativ gut. Es gibt offenbar viele Spam-Cancel-Bots und irgendwie scheint mir das Gefühl, dass das Spam-Aufkommen so ein wenig nachgelassen hat. Man sieht eigentlich relativ wenig Spam. Es ist also sehr erträglich im Vergleich zu dem, was ich so an Mail bekomme am Tag, an Spam. Da ist also ein Bruchteil nur im Usenet.
Was mir auffällt, wann immer ich mal im Usenet gucke, was relativ selten passiert, also ich hab so langsam kriege ich das Gefühl, als würden da nur noch irgendwelche verbitterten Menschen posten, die sich darüber beklagen, wie schlimm doch alles geworden ist und darüber hinaus aber sonst überhaupt keine Substanz haben. Das ist tatsächlich die Erfahrung, die ich gemacht habe. Wahrscheinlich lese ich ja andere Gruppen als du.
Ja, es gibt schon solche Gruppen. So eine meiner Lieblings-Hass-Gruppen ist da zum Thema Dekom Hemm, wo es um Arteurfunk geht, wo sehr viele Leute, die mal auf diese Beschreibung passt, posten, die irgendwie meinen, dass heute alles schlimm sei und dass alles sich zum Schlechten gewendet hätte.
Früher haben die Leserbriefe geschrieben. Früher haben die Leserbriefe geschrieben und uns in Ruhe gelassen.
Das kommt, glaube ich, ganz stark auf die Thematik an. In so einer Gruppe wie Desok Drogen, zum Beispiel treffen sich eben nicht solche Leute, wenn auch gleich wir in Desok Drogen einen Dauer-Troll haben, der uns immer vom christlichen Weg und das Drogen doch schlimm sei.
Wo ist denn der drauf?
Ja, weil der hat irgendwie auch so ein Domain, irgendwie laetdergutehirte.de oder so ein Kram.
Kannst du vielleicht, wo du es gerade erwähnst, vielleicht auch mal das Troll-Phänomen als solches nochmal beschreiben? Es war auch, glaube ich, gerade heute oder gestern ein interessanter Artikel dazu auf Spiegel Online. Und wie würdest du das definieren? Ein Troll?
Na ja, ein Troll ist jemand, also in der Regel sind das keine doofen Menschen. Das sind Menschen, die eigentlich genau wissen, was sie tun, die Spaß daran haben, andere aufs Glatteis zu führen, entweder mit irgendwelchen Geschichten. Das ist so besonders beliebt in diesen Selbsthilfegruppen, so in Detox-Liebesakt oder Detox-Romance. Das sind sehr schöne Storys zum Teil. Allerdings sind sie oft dann doch an einigen Detailstellen wenig schlecht ausgearbeitet und es fällt dann doch relativ schnell auf. Und die andere Gruppe, die so der Toll sind, die es bevorzugen zu provozieren. Das hat man mehr so in Webforen oder so, gerade so Heisen News Ticker, entweder so die Microsoft gegen die Linux Jünger oder halt irgendwie Apple gegen PC. Also da gibt es dann Leute, die sich da spezialisiert haben, da Unruhe zu stiften. Das ist so ungefähr die zwei Tollgruppen. Die Ersteren sind noch manchmal ganz lustig, wenn man nicht zu viele davon hat. Die anderen sind eigentlich nur noch lästig.
Also wie siehst du es dann schon?
Ja, also es gibt natürlich Leute, die sich schon sehr, sehr viel länger mit diesem Phänomen der sozialen Software und so weiter beschäftigen. Unter anderem gibt es das furchtbar lesenswerte Wiki Meatball, Meatball-Wiki, unter usemod und dann sich weiterklicken, usemod.com, weiterklicken zu Meatball-Wiki und da wurde auch so ein Lebenszyklus von so einer Community da mal beschrieben und da wurde halt auch gesagt, am Anfang gibt es den Gründer, der versucht das irgendwie dann in Gang zu bringen, dann läuft erstmal lange Zeit gar nichts und wenn dann eine kritische Masse erreicht ist, dann kommt die goldene Ära des Mediums. Die Leute tauschen sich aus, haben interessante Sachen zu erzählen und so weiter, dann funktioniert es eigentlich. Dann gibt es die Phase, wo das Ganze halt so groß ist, dass es dann halt für einfallende Barbarenhorden ein lohnendes Ziel bietet und dann muss sich die Gruppe entscheiden, wird sie einen Polizeistaat bilden oder wird sie zerbrechen. Es gibt dann auch Absplitterungstendenzen, dass Leute ein ganz anderes Medium aufmachen oder sagen, wir machen dann eine neue Mailingliste oder sowas und irgendwann wird das Medium dann entweder untergehen oder es wird sich den Regeln entsprechend verändern. Und ich glaube sowas ist halt auch dann im Usenet passiert. Also es gab halt mal diese Phase und da sind wir dann halt alle rausgegangen, als es völlig unerträglich war. Und jetzt scheint es wohl so zu sein, dass in einigen fokussierten Gruppen das Ganze ein bisschen kleiner, familiärer geworden ist, das Ganze sich wieder beruhigt hat und jetzt kann man es wieder empfehlen, bis die Barbaren halt wiederkommen.
Ja, würde ich so formulieren wollen, das ist schon richtig. Also wie gesagt, das International-Use-Net, das ist schon relativ kaputt. Wobei es natürlich auch solche und solche Gruppen gibt, aber so in Deutschland hat man es relativ in den Griff gekriegt, weil es gibt viele Leute, die lassen sich, also viele User, die einfach nicht zugucken, die auch Beschwerden schreiben, man Provider so, oder die einfach, was auch oft wirkt, ist einfach offen in den Gruppen oder auch per Mail gegen die Leute halt gegen argumentieren und sagen sonst einlassen und so. Es funktioniert eigentlich schon ganz gut mittlerweile die Selbstmoderation und die Selbstkontrolle im Newsnet und ich glaube es ist einfach, weil die Leute sich auch nicht mal so richtig stören lassen und so, über eine Zeit lang ist es einfach für die Trolls unattraktiv geworden. Also es ist schon ganz okay mit der Zeit.
Gucken wir einfach noch mal rein. Vielen Dank für deinen Anruf, Michael. Und gute Nacht.
Tschüss.
Und wo wir gerade beim Telefonieren waren, könnt ihr eigentlich auch weiter telefonieren, ne? Wen soll ich für dich mal anrufen, Tim?
Einen von deinen Freunden.
Ich hab keine Freunde. Doch, der Jens ist neuerdings mein Freund.
Du hast total viele Freunde. Ich kann jetzt mal nachgucken. Du hast Freunde, du hast fünf Freunde.
Sechs. Sechs.
Vielleicht solltet ihr das mal kurz einfach mal explizit erwähnen. Also das Usenet ist ja ein sehr altes System und jetzt kommen halt, also zur Kommunikation und jetzt kommen gerade sogenannte Social Networks auf. Die sind, naja, da kann man sich darüber streiten, ob das was Neues ist. Da wird auch gerade viel darüber gestritten. Tatsache ist, sie kommen gerade groß in Mode. Sie hören auf Namen wie FriendStar, MySpace, Monster, TribeNet oder eben auch Orkut. Flickr, die Liste ist ewig lang. Flickr? Also eine Faustauschkommune. Also es gibt Systeme, die jetzt sagen wir mal mehr diesen, was eigentlich mit der Hintergrundmusik? Es gibt Systeme, die sagen wir mal mehr auf diesen persönlichen Kontakt hinaus sind. Es gibt welche, die ganz speziell dieses Single-Dating und Kontakt, also Partnerbörsen, sich als solche auch verkaufen. Neu.de wird gerade überall groß plakatiert.
Ist da schon mal reingeguckt worden?
Ja, Neu.de ist ziemlich grausam. Männer müssen da 20 Euro zahlen, wenn sie irgendwie auch an dem Instant Messaging teilnehmen wollen. Ja, also das ist wirklich auch eines der ersten Systeme, wo mich die Nutzungsbestimmungen sozusagen ein bisschen vom Kopf gehauen haben. Also bei Orkut und anderen ist das auch alles ein bisschen fragwürdig. Auf Datenschutz müssen wir auch nochmal eingehen. Aber bei Neu.de war es so, in dem Moment, wo man halt ein Bild von sich hoch lädt, stimmt man auch gleichzeitig zu, dass es nicht nur im System verwendet wird, sondern nein, dass es auch unter anderem in einer Fernsehsendung, die sozusagen diesen Datenbestand aufgreift, verwendet werden darf.
Das kann das sein, dass ich das schon mal beim Zappen irgendwie nachts, wenn ich vom Blue Moon komme, auf TVB gesehen hab?
Dein Bild oder dein Bild, was ich anstatt dessen hochgeladen habe?
Franks Bild, was ich anstatt dir hochgeladen habe. Nein, aber kann das sein, dass das schon im Fernsehen kommt?
Ich weiß es nicht genau, ich kann mal fragen.
Da sind immer extrem, extrem schlecht qualitative Bilder, die da eingeblendet werden, während der läuft an der Seite so Newsticker-mäßig irgendwie so ein SMS-Chat, wo sich jeder daran beteiligen darf. Ich halt das immer nicht lange aus. Das ist auf demselben Sender, wo manchmal diese drei Mitverlaub-Schlampen sich räkeln.
Du meinst irgendwie diesen ehemaligen Frauensender, der jetzt 190er-Porno macht?
Ich weiß es nicht genau, welcher. Auf jeden Fall ist es hinter 34 bei mir.
Auch ein sehr schönes Beispiel für die Qualität des Rundfunkmanagements in Deutschland. Das war ja ein Frauensender.
Mit Bundesliga-Rechten sogar, oder?
Und jetzt hat er halt dann natürlich 190er-Porno.
Ja, also ich kommuniziere hier gerade mit verschiedenen Leuten. Das ist ganz lustig. Unser Sub-ETA-Dokument hat mittlerweile auch schon an die 15 Teilnehmer. Hier wird ganz fleißig gefeedbackt. Auf Tele5 ist wohl irgendwie Neue DE tatsächlich in irgendeiner Form schon verwurstet. Das ist eben auch ein wichtiger Punkt.
In Köln plakatieren die auch überall.
Überall. Also hier ist das nicht anders. Was sehr erfolgreich zu sein scheint, ist Friendster, die Bewusstpartner-Freundevermittlungen betreiben. Bei Friendster kann man auch relativ klar sagen, welche Informationen von einem selber sehen darf. Also erstmal kann man natürlich entscheiden, was man selber veröffentlicht. Das ist das eine. Aber eben auch wer jetzt direkt das sehen kann. Es gibt ja so eine Sperre. Man kann eben die Profile von Leuten nicht sehen, wenn man nicht mindestens über fünf Leute mit denen verbunden ist. Also sozusagen Freund eines Freundes, eines Freundes, eines Freundes. Andere Systeme verfolgen da andere Ansätze. Orkut zum Beispiel hat ein komplett offenes Netz. Das heißt, man kann im Prinzip das Profil von jedem erstmal sehen, wobei man selber bestimmen kann, was davon konkret sichtbar ist für direkte Freunde oder eben Freunde von Freunden oder eben dann darüber hinaus.
War es nicht anstrengend, das alles zu klicken, basteln, konfigurieren?
Wir haben uns da ein bisschen durchgeklickt in der Vorbereitung für die Sendung. Tim hatte das so schön auf den Punkt gebracht, Orkut ist halt irgendwie das System für die Nerds und Fenster mehr für die Mädchen.
23 Uhr haben wir es. Sie hört Chaosradio 89. Wollen wir ein bisschen telefonieren? Bitte. 0331 70 97 110 ist die Nummer, unter der ihr gefragt seid, hier im Radio mit zu reden, mit uns, mit allen anderen und für alle anderen. Die Frage an euch ist, welcherlei Social Software, soziale Software oder soziale Netzwerke benutzt ihr?
Genau, benutzt ihr das?
Habt ihr schon interessante Bekanntschaften darüber gemacht? Oder auch vielleicht schlechte Erfahrungen damit gesammelt? Habt ihr neue Freundinnen gewonnen? Oder vielleicht sogar Lebenspartner? Oder verloren? Oder verloren oder abgeben müssen an andere Freunde aus eurer Freundesliste? Das würde uns auf jeden Fall sehr interessieren, wie eure Erfahrungen da sind und welchen System ihr dann auch konkret gearbeitet habt.
0331 70 97 110. Fanny van Danen und Freundinnen.
Der ist ja schon überrepräsentiert.
Ja, tut mir leid, wir spielen dann nachher noch Alexandra. Ja, du wolltest das, ich hab damit nichts zu tun. Ich hab damit überhaupt nichts zu tun. Chaosradio 89, Social Networking ist das Thema hier in Blumenau, Fritz. Und 0331 70 97 110, die Telefonnummer, unter der ihr gefragt seid, zu antworten auf die Frage, welcherlei soziale Netzwerke benutzt ihr, auf welche Art und Weise und welche Erfahrungen habt ihr damit gemacht? Norman?
Ja, wir hören dich. Wir hören dich. Ich hab hier gerade kleine Probleme, weil es wird egal. Ich hab hier nur zufällig bei euch mit reingehört und da dachte ich, ich muss mal meinen Senf dazu geben. Und zwar über eine Internetflirtlein hatte ich auch mal Mädel kennengelernt. Die hat unten in Baden-Württemberg gelernt, gearbeitet, gewohnt, arbeitet in der Schweiz. Und ja, es war eine super Frau, um diese Frau kennenzulernen. Also durch die italische Mentalität und so, so einen Menschen, den trifft man hier in Berlin niemals. Die hat so ein herzensgutes Gemüt und ja, also so einen tollen Menschen trifft man hier wirklich niemals.
Entschuldigung, wo hast du die kennengelernt?
Welcher Flirtlein hast du die denn kennengelernt?
Warte mal dran, so Flirt Fever oder so. Das war auch nur kurzzeitig abends so gewesen.
Was ist das, ein Chat oder was? Ist das ein Chat oder was?
Ja, das ist so ein Flirtlein-Chat, so vital du bist, so alles mit da drin. Und ja, das war auch eher echt langweilig und überhaupt nichts von erwartet und hat sich echt gelohnt, wirklich.
Und wie hast du die dann konkret angesprochen oder hat sie dich angesprochen?
Ja, das war eigentlich, ich hab ich jetzt echt nur, also ich bin da nicht ran gehangen und hab mir gedacht, ja, okay, ich soll jetzt hier eine Frau kennenlernen, weil es eh Schwachsinn über das Internet, so meine Meinung. Und das verlief sich dann über einige Monate, ab und zu mal eine Mail geschrieben, ein E-Mail-Interesse ausgetauscht, später Telefonnummern, dann hat man auch mal Zestnis ausgetauscht und es lief dann im Endeffekt darauf hinaus, dass wir uns täglich miteinander telefoniert haben und dass dann doch über ein, zwei Stunden so ein Telefonat gedauert hat.
Aber doch wieder telefonieren, ne?
Ja, und ey, unser eins als Mann, ich meine, man ist ja doch eher so drauf, telefonieren, ja klar, klar und tschau, wir sehen uns, ne? Und ähm, das häng ich, ey, wenn man dann zwei oder drei Stunden mit einer Frau telefoniert und das nicht nur so den Hörer dabei legt und irgendwie zuhört, sondern wirklich, äh, einem doch nahegeht, was diese Frau erzählt. Also, das ist dann doch schon etwas Besonderes. Ja, also auf jeden Fall, ich denke, man kann auch Glück haben, aber ich denke, das meiste, was da so abläuft, ist echt nur Verarschung.
Ach, tatsächlich.
Na, bei dir schien ja die Quote nicht wirklich schlecht zu sein.
Ja, von zwei Versuchen, ein Volltreffer, ist schon genial, aber ich denke, das ist nicht repräsentativ für alle.
Also wissenschaftlich erwiesen ist es, dass es nicht das meiste Verarschung ist. Also es gibt so eine hübsche Zahl von Bruce Schneier, der viel über Sicherheitstechnik schreibt, über Kryptographie und so weiter. Und der hat mal gesagt, man muss sich einfach mal vor Augen führen, nur ein Prozent aller Überweisungen bei Ebay führen, wirklich dann zu klagen. Das heißt, wir können davon ausgehen, dass 99 Prozent aller Menschen gut und ehrlich sind.
Aber was die Realität so einem noch mal darbietet, machen wir nicht.
Immerhin bei dir hat die Realität ja sich, jetzt fehlt mir jetzt das richtige Adjektiv.
Aber die Realität hat voll zugeschlagen.
Genau, aber herzlichen Glückwunsch Norman und vielen Dank für deinen Anruf. Ja, falls ihr euch noch äußern wollt zu Social Networking 0331 77 97 110. Uns würde interessieren, welche Art soziale Netzwerke ihr benutzt. Also jetzt natürlich online, also nicht die, die ihr ohnehin benutzt. 0331 77 97 110.
Also ich hab natürlich auch schon einige Leute befragt, wie denn so ihre Erfahrungen sind. Und zu meiner größten Überraschung hab ich da auch ziemlich viel Positives gehört. Sowohl bei Orkut. Jemand erzählte mir so, ja, er hätte dann einfach mal bei Orkut nach Woman Single Germany gesucht. Da gab es dann irgendwie gar nicht so viel Auswahl. Drei oder vier oder fünf dürften das gewesen sein, weil dann haben wir natürlich alle schon mal gesucht. Und er wäre dann sozusagen mal in Kontakt getreten und über ein paar Tage hinweg hätte sich dann tatsächlich was ergeben in seinem Raum. Irgendwo im Münchner Raum. Und die sind jetzt zusammen, meinte er. Ich weiß nicht, ob das noch hält oder so, aber es hat tatsächlich stattgefunden. Und ähnliche Paarungswilligkeit gibt es wohl auch bei Friendster. Sehr ausgeprägter Form. Es muss ja auch nicht hier dann unbedingt gleich in Liebesbeziehungen enden. Aber ich denke, da ist ein gewisser Reiz, das einfach mal auszuprobieren. Insbesondere bei den Jungen, die sind da auch relativ unbedarft. Die machen sich auch nicht so viel Gedanken.
Die jungen Menschen oder die Kerle? Die jungen Menschen.
Und sind natürlich sehr unbedarft und gehen da eigentlich auch erstmal so spaßorientiert ran und machen sich jetzt nicht so viele Gedanken über Privatsphäre und Datenschutz, wie das jetzt die alten Knacker dann doch vielleicht mal eher tun. Und naja gut, das sind halt für alle erstmal Experimente. Das haben wir ja eben auch rausgehört. Oh, ich hab ja nichts erwartet, ich probier's halt einfach mal. Und in der Phase befinden sich glaube ich die meisten dieser Kontaktbörsen gerade.
Zumindest also, all zu viele Nutzer haben sie nicht oder uns hört keiner mehr zu. Denn drüber reden wollen die wenigsten. Unter 0331 70 97 1 1 0. Wollen wir eine Zigarettenpause machen, Jens?
Ja, man kann ja noch mal ein bisschen vorstellen. Also es gibt ja sehr viele Versuche solche Systeme an Start zu kriegen. Ganz interessant ist auch zu sehen, welche Techniken dabei benutzt werden. Also sowas wie Friendster und Orkut benutzen halt im Wesentlichen das Web. Auch der ganze Nachrichtenaustausch und diese Diskussionsforen ist alles webbasiert. Das heißt, es gibt eigentlich den Webbrowser als einziges Frontend. Es gibt auch Systeme, die benutzen Instant Messaging. Zum Beispiel gibt es dieses love.com, das habe ich jetzt selber noch nicht ausprobiert. Das ist so an den IEM-Dienst mit rangepackt. Und auch dieses neude benutzt irgendwie einen Instant Messaging. Ich weiß aber jetzt nicht genau, ob die sozusagen öffentliche Instant Messaging-Systeme benutzen oder ihr eigenes IEM-System haben. Vielleicht kann mich da noch mal einer aufklären. Und das ist so das Modell, was die meisten haben. Neben den ganzen Freundes- und Kontaktbörsen gibt es allerdings auch noch einen anderen interessanten Zweig, der ziemlich flogiert, wie es den Anschein hat. Das sind diese business-orientierten Kontaktbörsen.
Bleiben wir gerade nochmal bei Orkut, da ruft nämlich Jana aus Dortmund an.
Bleiben wir bei Orkut.
Ja ich wollte eigentlich schon längst geschlafen haben, aber dank eurer wunderschönen Musikauswahl hat das wieder nicht geklappt.
Keine Ursache, das war ich ja gar nicht.
Also zum Thema Orkut wollte ich was sagen. Ich bin auch irgendwie Orkut-Mitglied seit geraumer Zeit. Und zwar war das so, dass es im Irrkalt rumging, dass keiner gesagt hat, wer will Mitglied werden, sondern alle gesagt haben, ja ich hab eine neue Community gegründet und keiner wusste, worum es eigentlich geht. Das heißt, es war irgendwie so eine geheimnisumwitterte Sache.
Exklusivität.
Ganz genau. Dann hab ich mir das irgendwie so zwei Tage angelesen und irgendwann weiß ich dann halt doch Mitglied. Und dann war das irgendwie, ich glaub eine Woche lang hat man jeden geadded, den man irgendwie kannte oder nicht kannte und 5000 Communities gegründet und reingegangen. Und jetzt ist es im Moment so, es ist einfach tot. Hab ich so einen Eindruck, es ist irgendwie so ein System, was geschaffen wurde, das überhaupt keinen Sinn und Zweck hat.
Naja, immerhin zum Beispiel Tim, also dass ich Tims iChat Namen kannte und den jetzt in meinen iChat mit übernehmen konnte. Und darum brauch ich ja auch nicht unbedingt Orkut, um mit Tim in Kontakt zu drehen.
Eben, das ist so eine Sache, weil ich bin über Orkut jetzt auch nur mit Leuten connectet, die ich halt im IRC hab, die ich im ICQ hab, die ich im richtigen Leben hab. Ich brauch Orkut eigentlich gar nicht.
Du kannst auch unser Freund werden.
Genau, guck doch mal, wir haben eine Community gebastelt, die hast...
Ja, ich bin sicher, dass wir irgendwie über zwei Ecken fünfmal verknüpft sind.
Ja natürlich, alle. Wir haben eine schöne Community gebastelt, die heißt Radio Fritz. Und dann gibt es auch noch eine, die heißt CCC, da kann ich noch vorbeischauen.
Ja, CCC bin ich ja schon drin.
Radio Fritz hab ich doch neulich gebastelt, als wir miteinander...
Ja, ja stimmt.
Ich sag jetzt nicht, was wir miteinander haben, aber...
Nichts gemeint haben.
Doch, warte mal. Wir sind immerhin Freunde. Außerdem hab ich einen Fan und das bist du. Und das liegt nur daran, dass ich nicht weiß, wie man da einen Fan einträgt.
Das weißt du nicht? Mensch. Das ist ganz einfach. Aber das User Interface ist auch nicht unbedingt jetzt das Großartigste, was die Welt bisher gesehen hat.
Nee, auch gut, das ist wirklich mangelhaft, muss man sagen.
Na, es ist halt einfach so aus visualstudio.net rausgefallen. Und ich hab auch das Gefühl, da wird nicht mehr richtig viel dran geschraubt. Obwohl es viele Feature-Requests gibt. Aber die Frage, Jana, die du gestellt hast, die stellen wir uns alle. Wofür ist das denn jetzt eigentlich gut?
Eigentlich wäre es ja, wenn man diese Communities hätte. Man kann ja auch eigene Foren darin schreiben, wenn da wirklich was passieren würde. Aber das Problem ist halt, dass ich in diesen Communities nur mit Leuten drin bin, mit denen ich ohnehin irgendwie anders verknüpft bin. Sei es, dass ich irgendwie, bei mir sind jetzt zum Beispiel Webcomics. Aber diese Webcomics haben alle eigene Foren irgendwo. Das heißt, das wird im Prinzip von niemandem verwendet. Also ich hab zumindest mir nicht aufgefallen, dass außer dieser Orkut Design Community in keiner irgendwie ein reger Verkehr herrschen würde.
In den vielen Communities, wo über Orkut geschimpft wird, es geht richtig die Post ab.
Echt?
Wir müssen sich dringend joinen, da war ich noch nicht.
Hast du gesagt, du bist auch in der CTC Community? Aber dann bist du nicht unter deinem eigenen Namen in Orkut, richtig?
Genau das wollte ich auch gerade sagen. Tatsächlich? Ach nee, wirklich?
Warum sehe ich dich denn da nicht da drin?
Doch, ganz sicher, warte mal. Ihr müsst wissen, wie man meinen Vornamen schreibt, das sage ich jetzt aber nicht. Probiert von mit Doppel N und H hinten.
Wann?
Ah, du bist eine Bekannte von Enno.
Alles klar, jetzt müssen wir zumindest mit wem was zu tun haben.
Das finde ich ehrlich gesagt ganz schön.
Das ist doch lustig.
Du bist zum Beispiel so eine Person, da habe ich auch schon ein paar Mal drauf gelandet, da haben mich immer gefragt, wer das Wort ist.
Ja, ich auch, ich auch.
Ihr habt schon ganz viele Fan-Mails gekriegt. Tatsächlich? Die haben mir auch geschrieben, haben gesagt, ach du bist so nett und wir sind über 15 Leute verknüpft und bla bla bla.
Du bist so nett, woher wissen sie denn das? Ich meine, da wird ja überhaupt nichts, du sagst ja auch gar nichts, du bist ja nur Freunde, irgendwie, du bist minimal gekleidet und hast keine Kinder.
Ich sage überhaupt nichts über mich, weil ich das halt ziemlich albern fand, da irgendwie meinen gesamten Lebenslauf eingekippert.
Och, ich fand das einfach nur zu anstrengend albern.
Also eigentlich ist die einzig sinnvolle Anwendung von Orkut bisher, dass man feststellen kann, über wen man tatsächlich wen kennt. Also auf welchen Party man wahrscheinlich jemand getroffen hat, oder wo halt einfach gemeinsame Freunde sind.
Ich glaube ganz spannend war auch dieses Real-Life-Namen-Merken. Das war ja, man kennt ja immer nur die Nicknames. Und dann kriegt man mal Gesicht und den richtigen Namen zusammen.
Ja, falls jemand den richtigen Namen da reinschreibt.
Ja, aber das ist ja auch so schlecht nicht.
Das ist aber nicht die einzige sinnvolle Anwendung. Also noch eine, die ich mir vorstellen kann, ist einfach als Adressbuch. Du schreibst deine Anschrift, deine Telefonnummer da rein und sagst, das will ich aber nur, dass das meine Freunde sehen. Und du kannst es dann einer nicht so ganz bestimmten Gruppe zur Verfügung stellen. Aber du stellst es nicht ins ganze Internet. Und irgendwie jeder Adressenspammer kann das dann abgreifen. Sondern halt einer Gruppe, wo du denkst, na gut, die werden wahrscheinlich damit keinen Schindluder treiben. Aber die Gruppe beschränke ich jetzt erstmal nicht, dass ich da jetzt wirklich jeden freischalten muss. Sondern dass ich einfach nur sage, meine Friends, meine Freunde.
Das mit den Friends ist auch so eine Sache. Ich hatte da auch schon die merkwissen Leute, die gesagt haben, lasst mich dein Freund sein. Wo ich gesagt habe, ich hab euch noch nie im Leben gesehen. Ich weiß nicht, wer ihr seid.
Na, Orkut-Freundschaften werden ja jetzt auch verkauft. Auf Ebay zum Beispiel.
Ja, hab ich gesehen.
Entschuldigung, es gibt auch was?
Einladungen, ne? Einladungen für Orkut werden verkauft. Ich glaube im Moment 10 Dollar oder sowas. Es gibt jemanden, der unterbietet den Preis. Also der ist irgendwie im Wahlkampfteam von Howard Dean gewesen, bis Howard Dean nicht mehr Präsidentschaftskandidat war. Und der hat dann gesagt, okay, bei mir kriegt er das schon ab 2 Dollar. Und einfach hier klicken, hier ist mein Paypal-Account.
Echt, das mach ich auch.
Na ja, also Orkut hat ja diesen Gründungsmythos, von wegen es kommt von Google, es ist cool. Die ersten Einladungen gingen nur an Google-Mitarbeiter und an ausgewählte Stars. Und was habe ich zu Hause gesessen und mir die Fingernägel abgeknabbert, weil ich gedacht habe, wann geht diese scheiß Einladungswelle mal endlich um Globus und da reicht irgendwie auch Deutschland, wo ich sitze und dass ich dann endlich auch mal meine Einladung kriege.
Hat ja nicht so lange gedauert.
Hat nicht lange gedauert, nein.
Und ich hab dann auch gleich dich eingeladen, Tim.
Ja und Tim hat gleich mich eingeladen.
Ich hab den Michael von vorhin eingeladen.
Ja und jetzt ist er dein Fan, wenn man sehen kann.
Tatsächlich? Wie macht man denn ein Fan aus? Ich hab jetzt erstmal Jana als meine Freundin. Hab ich mir ausgesucht.
Das heißt, du müsstest mich jetzt eigentlich einloggen und nachgucken.
Ja natürlich müsstest du das eigentlich tun.
Warte mal, das können wir jetzt mal live ausprobieren.
Genau, Orkut live im Radio.
Du klangst auch freundlich genug, dass du mein Freund wärst.
Benutzt du den eigentlich sonst noch?
Ich bin eigentlich mal gespannt, wie viele Leute ich gleich hier stehen hab, wenn ich mich eingeloggt hab.
Genau, Leute, Jana in Orkut.
Benutzt du denn sonst noch irgendwas Jana?
Was heißt irgendwas?
Naja, irgendwelche Social Software darüber hinaus.
Was heißt irgendwelche Social Software? Ja, Newsgroups lösen, IRC und was es da so ums auch geht, aber dieses Netzwerkdingen so gar nicht. Ich fand's halt auch nur interessant, weil alle darüber geredet haben. Und es ist, ja, wenn man drin ist, überhaupt nicht mehr interessant. Aber solange man nicht drin ist, find ich's eigentlich doch.
Was ich so ein bisschen frappierend fand, war dieser so Freunde-wie-Briefmarkensammeln-Effekt. Also dass die Leute halt einfach anfangen, irgendwie wahllos, jeden, der da des Weges kommt, dazu adden, nur um irgendwie eine deutlich zweistellige Anzahl Freunde zu kriegen.
Pokémon-Karten find ich eigentlich einen besseren Vergleich. Und ich hab jetzt einen Tim Prittlaff in meiner Sammlung und der hat folgendes Spezialkräfte und könnte ich den tauschen gegen. Also es wäre eigentlich schon schön, wenn man...
Das wäre übrigens super, wenn du ins Mikrofon sprechen könntest. Jens ist der, der die ganze Zeit am Mikrofon vorbeispricht, warum er so schwer zu verstehen ist.
Und der andere Folge?
Das bin ich.
Okay.
Und ich bin Tim.
Jana, ich sag jetzt mal danke für deinen Anruf, bevor du das hier noch weiter ausruferst. Geh mal dringend schlafen, Jana.
Vielen Dank, tschüss.
Ich wünsch euch noch was, tschüss.
Dir auch, tschau.
031 70 97 110. Welche Art soziale Netzwerke und soziale Software benutzt ihr? fragt das Chaosradio 89 auf Fritz.
Zum Thema, was noch so interessant sein könnte.
Wir haben hier ein Mikrofon.
Ja, Entschuldigung. Zum Thema, was noch sozusagen der Nutzen sein könnte. Dieses Kennenlernen, ich finde schon, dass es ein Kennenlernen ist. Weil, was zum Beispiel jetzt noch dazu kommt, sind ja diese Testimonials, wie das bei Orkut so schön heißt. Das heißt, man kann aus freien Stücken Bewertungen schreiben für andere Leute. Wenn man das tut, muss derjenige, der sie erhält, sie auch noch bestätigen, damit sie dann auch tatsächlich in der persönlichen Profilseite auftaucht. Und dann steht das da halt. Das heißt, man sieht explizit, andere Leute äußern sich eben dazu. Man hat ja eben schon gemerkt, dieses Friend-Wort schafft Konfusion. Wer ist mein Freund? Und dann gibt es viele Leute, die sind dann gleich wieder aus Orkut abgehauen und sagen, alle wollen hier nur einen auf den dicken machen. Und das ist mir alles viel zu schlimm. Und so mache ich nicht mit. Aber wenn man das halt einfach mal ein bisschen entspannter sieht und sagt, okay, das ist jetzt einfach ein Bekanntschaftensystem, wie auch immer diese Bekanntschaft aussieht, könnte man zum Beispiel diese Testimonials eben dazu benutzen, die eigentliche Qualifizierung dieser Freundschaftsbewertung zu betreiben. Oder auch dieses, ich bin ein Fan von... Dazu kommt ja noch, man kann ja ja Seriosität und irgendwie Eiswürfel anklicken.
Ich will ja immer noch gerne mal bei dir anklicken, Report as Bogus. Wie kriege ich denn das jetzt hin, dass man jetzt einen Fan machen kann? Wie kann ich denn dein Fan sein?
Dann musst du mal oben auf Friends klicken und dann gibt es da so komische Icon. So ganz oben direkt neben dem Namen, neben deinem Namen rechts gibt es so vier Taps mit so komischen Männchen. Und dann gibt es so ein Männchen mit so Smiley und Sternchen.
Männchen mit Sternchen. Ach, das ist ja allerliebst. So ja, 5.5er lade ich euch zur Orgut ein oder ihr ruft an 0331 77 97 120. Chaosradio 89 ist was ihr hört und Social Networking, unser Thema. Jetzt finden wir das ja alles ganz toll, ne, Tim? So sag ich jetzt mal. Google bastelt Orkut und das hat nichts miteinander zu tun und Google hat überhaupt kein Interesse daran, ein Profil anzulegen, wo drin steht, der Holger, der sucht immer nach den Sachen und hat diese Telefonnummer. Ich mein, früher oder später wird doch einer bei mir anrufen.
Ja, wenn deine Telefonnummer da drin steht, dann ist das ja wahrscheinlich auch der Sinn der Sache, oder nicht?
Das ging davor auch schon.
Steht deine Telefonnummer da drin? Ja klar, Holger hat nichts zu verbergen.
Nein, ich dachte, Tim hat es auch reingeschrieben.
Das ist so wie bei Trio, die auf ihrem zweiten Album den Satz gebracht haben, ja, auf der Rückseite des ersten Albums haben wir unsere Telefonnummer veröffentlicht, daraufhin haben uns viele Leute angerufen.
Das hat uns bewogen, auf dem zweiten Album unsere Kontonummer zu veröffentlichen. Vielleicht solltest du das mal probieren.
Aber bei allem Spaß, also diese Datenschutzsache ist eigentlich eine der ernsteren Aspekte von Orkut. Einen haben wir eben schon ein bisschen, Tim meinte irgendwie, das ein wenig ironisierend, aber für viele Leute, die das halt ernster nehmen mit dem Begriff Friend, war dann irgendwie der Spaß zu Ende, und die haben sich dann bei Orkut austragen lassen, weil sie meinten, ich will irgendwie mein soziales Netzwerk nicht gespeichert haben und vielleicht auch nicht irgendwie in den Vereinigten Staaten, wo ganz andere Datenschutzrechtlinien gelten als bei uns. Das war eigentlich auch eine der Hauptkritikpunkte bei Orkut in der Hacker-Szene im CTC-Umfeld. Wir sind alle so ein bisschen hin und her gerissen, also ich bin es immer noch. Einerseits ist es toll, weil es ein neues Spielzeug ist, und neue Spielzeuge sind immer toll. Andererseits wollen die wirklich verdammt viel von einem wissen. Man kann da wirklich seine ganze Persönlichkeit ausbreiten und dann halt auch schön indizierbar in der Datenbank von Google den Datenkraken überhaupt aufbereiten lassen.
Ich erinnere an Herrn Malotki. I'm pretty hairy, schreibt er. Ich bin ziemlich haarig.
Mal gucken, womit der zugespent wird.
Ich meine, Orkut ist ja noch einigermaßen harmlos. Es gibt natürlich auch noch die etwas expliziteren Varianten im Netz, die halt einfach dann halt schon als... Also bei Orkut kann man ja im Wesentlichen nichts sagen, kann man nur seinen Namen eingeben und sagen, ich sag nichts, wenn man möchte. Also es gibt ja keine Required Forms. Und es gibt halt noch andere Services, wo halt irgendwie Angabe-Requirement ist, halt irgendwie Länge der Premiere, Geschlechtsmerkmale und irgendwie...
Echt, kann ich da mal die Adresse...
Ihr wollt sie wirklich haben, das gibt es zum Beispiel.
Nein, nein, es ist noch vorm Mittendacht, wir machen keine Wagen für diese Leute.
Ist das hier kostenlose Mitgliedschaft, neue Freunde und Sexpartner kennenlernen?
Ja, solche Sachen.
Ahja, Millionenprofile mit sexy Fotos.
Genau, sowas.
Nicht schlecht, kostet was?
Naja, ich warne dich gleich mal vor, die Fotos sind nicht wirklich das, was wir als sexy bezeichnen würden.
Das ist wahrscheinlich bei Orkut besser aufgehoben.
Also sagen wir so, es bleibt nichts, der Fantasie überlässt. Aber diese Sachen bilden natürlich einen wesentlichen Teil von diesen Community-Geschichten ab. Also bei Orkut ist es halt immer noch alles halbwegs zivilisierter, da sind halt die Geeks unter sich. Und es gibt natürlich noch irgendwie die etwas proletarischen Dinge, die dann halt einigermaßen direkt zum Punkt kommen. Für mich ist das eigentlich so eine Tendenz, dass ich halt einfach die Communities, wie man früher sagen würde, heute würde man halt Social Software-Systeme sagen, segmentieren nach Interessen, also worum es eigentlich tatsächlich geht. Es gibt halt die Business-Geschichten, da kommen wir ein kleines bisschen später darauf. Es gibt halt irgendwie die, ich brauch halt irgendjemand zum Ficken-Porade und es gibt halt so die ganz normalen, sag ich mal, oh gut, wem möchte ich kennenlernen, kenn ich die Leute, was auch immer. Und da segmentiert sich das halt. Die Frage natürlich, was gibt man da an, ist die schwierige. Natürlich ist der Reiz groß, möglichst viel reinzuschreiben, damit man möglichst interessante Leute kennenlernt, aber nachdem man sich da ein bisschen bewegt hat, wird einem vollkommen klar, dass es total egal ist, weil die meisten Leute gucken eh nur auf das Foto und lesen die Profile nicht, oder es interessiert sich eigentlich nicht, was in den Profilen steht oder so ähnlich halt. Insofern, meine persönliche Intention war einfach zu sagen, ok, alles was man eh über mich in Google finden kann, steht da auch drin und mehr halt nicht.
Genau.
Das war so die Grundregel. Interessanterweise haben mehrere andere Leute gesagt, ok, genau das ist auch das, was sie getan haben, das was eh über mich im Netz ist, kann auch drinstehen. Alles andere halt nicht.
Ja, ein Lied für Freunde. Über Freunde und den Baum im Chaosradio 89 mit dem Thema Social Networking. Die Frage, die wir euch gestellt haben und die ihr bitte beantwortet unter 03317797110 lautet, welcherlei soziale Netzwerke oder soziale Software benutzt ihr eigentlich?
Und wie nehmt ihr es mit dem Datenschutz?
Und wie nehmt ihr es mit dem Datenschutz? Andre? Welche Frage willst du zuerst beantworten?
Ähm, in Sachen hier Communities, Chats und so. Ähm, nee, ich find das eigentlich total okay mit diesen Chats, weil da lernt man gut Leute kennen und so. Also ich hab zum Beispiel jetzt so ziemlich viele Leute im Chat kennengelernt, mit denen ich mich dann auch so persönlich getroffen habe und die sind eigentlich auch voll okay.
Welchen Chat benutzt du denn?
Welche Chats benutzt du denn?
Wie du weißt?
Was ist das?
Ja, klingt ein bisschen komisch.
Also www.knudels.de Ja, genau.
Gibt da halt 10 Zählen.
Knudels.de Woher soll ich das gehört haben? Boah, Alter, das ist aber ein bisschen bunt, oder?
Ja, eigentlich ist das ganz lustig. Da muss man sich zwar anmelden, aber vorher, bevor man da überhaupt rankommt. Aber ansonsten ist das eigentlich ganz okay so.
Und was gibst du da von dir so an? Wie viel gibst du da von dir so Preis? Also wie viel erzählst du da so über dich in den Profilen? Also wenn du dich da registrierst?
Wie bitte?
Wie viel muss man da so von sich angeben, wenn man sich da registriert tut?
Eigentlich braucht man da nicht viel angeben. Nur E-Mail-Adresse und halt sein Name, wie man so heißen soll, und sein Passwort. Ansonsten ist der eigentlich nicht so wichtig.
Die Statistiken sind halt auch eindeutig. So 1776 Leute in Flirt und 1154 in Lokalrund. Alle anderen sind so unter Fana Liefen.
So legendär Flirt.de.
Wie hältst du das da so mit deinem Kommunikationsverhalten? Findest du da wirklich neue Freunde? Oder redest du da eben nur mit Leuten, die du kennst?
Na ja, also, nee, teilweise neue Freunde hab ich da gefunden. Mit denen, da teilweise machen wir auch oft ein Zuma-CT, also Chatter-Treffen. Und dann treffen wir uns alle mal so gemeinsam. Und dann lernen wir uns halt mal so persönlich kennen.
Tatsächlich, also ist das nicht so, dass du ein fürchterlich enttäuscht bist?
Nö, eigentlich nicht. Na ja, es gibt Leute, die nicht so besonders da viel Preis geben oder halt viel sagen. Über sich selbst und so.
Aber...
Tuest du das?
Ja, ich geb eigentlich ziemlich viel über mich Preis.
Zum Beispiel?
Na ja, halt Wohnort und meine Hobbys und alles Mögliche.
Machst du dir Gedanken über deine Identität, die du im Netz hast? Also wenn du irgendwie Daten angibst, wenn du chattest und so weiter, überlegst du dir dann, ja, das bleibt jetzt erstmal im Internet und wenn ich dann in 10, 20 Jahren einen Job suche, dann ist das dann über Google erreichbar.
Hm, nee, so, also, äh, ich pass schon, eigentlich pass ich schon oft, was ich so angebe, also zu viel jeweg nicht an, aber...
Was für Hobbys hast du denn?
Ja, und interessant fand ich, dass der Chef einer von diesen Communities oder Social Software Geschichten, tribes.net, da meinte man, naja, wir müssen jetzt allmählich lernen, damit umzugehen, was wir in solchen Communities sagen, bzw. in solchen Social Software Networks sagen, weil möglicherweise ist es halt in ein paar Jahren nicht so ganz gut, dass der Chef mit zwei Klicks sehen kann, dass man Mitglied der Local Leather Community ist, die sich Mitglieder uns Banking beschäftigt.
Okay, ich nehm mal meine Telefonnummer da raus, jetzt.
Also da ist schon was dran, ich denke, dass genau dieses Lernen ist halt genau das, was gerade passiert.
Kannst du dir das überhaupt vorstellen, dass jetzt irgendjemand diese von dir angegebenen Daten und die Informationen, mit wem du kommunizierst, für irgendwelche bösen Machenschaften verwenden könnte?
Ja, vorstellen könnte ich, kann ich mir das schonen, aber so... Also mir kommt dieser Chat so, ist eigentlich ziemlich seriös drüber.
Gibt es denn in dem System auch die Möglichkeit zu sagen, wer deine Freunde sind oder ist das gar nicht Teil des Systems?
Na ja, da gibt es sozusagen so eine Freundschaftsliste, die man dann so hat und da kann man dann so seine Freunde einnehmen, also mit denen man sich dann so unterhält, die kann man dann da einspeichern.
Hast du viele Freunde? So dreistellig?
Nee, mehr zweistellig so. Aber mit Leuten, die man sich so unterhält, da kommt so eine Menge Leute zusammen eigentlich.
Ich meine, wenn jetzt einer deiner Freunde in eine Bank überfällt, dass dann sozusagen in den verdächtigen Kreis aufgenommen wirst, der Gedanke ist dir noch nicht gekommen?
Obwohl du eine zweistellige Freundeanzahl hast.
Würdest du mich jetzt als besonders paranoid bezeichnen, wenn ich diese Vermutung äußere oder hast du da bloß noch nie drüber nachgedacht?
Naja, mir hat jetzt noch keiner so eine Äußerung zukommen lassen. Also kommt drauf an, wenn ich die Person nicht kenne, die mir das erzählt. Also nicht von etwas länger kenne, vom Chatten her sozusagen. Also da würde ich den denn... Naja, ich würde ihn erstmal fragen, wie er so was machen würde und so. Und wie so er das vorhat. Und ich sehe nicht...
Wie er was vorhat?
Banküberfall? Banküberfall.
Achso, du meinst, es gibt das erstmal im Chat Preis? Das glaube ich nicht. Ich glaube, das würde eher stattfinden, wenn es sozusagen schon gelaufen ist. Und dann kommen sozusagen die Herren in den grünen Anzügen und sagen sie, sagen sie mal, sie sind doch ein Freund von dem und dem. Das kenne ich doch gar nicht, aber wir haben das doch in digital.
Dann hältst du ihm eben einfach die Übersetzung von Friend aus dem Leo-Dictionary vor. So war das nicht gemeint, Herr.
Auch Bekannte sind verdächtig.
Ja, so lief ja die Rastverfangung ab. Also als man dann irgendwie angefangen hat, irgendwie so Terroristen zu überprüfen, hat man dann auch gleich alle Leute, die mit dem Terroristen in einem Bahnabteil saßen, mit aufgenommen. Und die hat man dann halt auch weiter verfolgt. Und wenn die dann wieder Bahn gefahren sind, musste man halt auch alle anderen erfassen. Und auch dieses System, neues Fremdwort gelernt heute, skalierte nicht und brach dann irgendwann zusammen.
André, nichtsdestotrotz, danken wir für deinen Anruf und entlassen dich jetzt in die Nacht. Und guten Abend Manuel.
Ja, ich wollte erzählen, wie sich das bei mir so verändert hat.
Ja, was benutzt du nun?
Früher hatte ich das so benutzt, ich hatte von einem Freund einen Link bekommen, alhumora.de, die Seite geht nicht mehr.
Die ist wie?
alhumora.de, das war so eine El-Potter-Fan-Seite. Und da gab es so einen Main-Chat. Das ist so eine besondere Art von Chat. Es war sehr lustig.
Was macht diesen Chat besonders?
Na ja, es nimmt sehr viel Speicher ein. Ja, das ist wirklich schrecklich. Man muss dauernd auf Reset drücken, damit ein Model nicht abstürzt.
Darüber hast du dann die Freunde kennengelernt, die alle das gleiche Problem hatten.
Selbsthilfegruppe. Selbsthilfegruppe quasi.
Ja, die hatten meistens DSL oder so. Und ja, da hab ich die kennengelernt. Das waren eigentlich ganz nese Leute. Und dann auf einmal wurde der Chat von irgendjemand anderem übernommen. Da wurde dann geschlossen. Kurz danach. Dann hatte ich erst mal so ein Jahr gar nichts mehr so. Und dann hatte ich das Spiel Leselfader 2 entdeckt. Und da wollte ich mich einen Plan anmelden. Und dazu brauchte man eine ICQ. Ja, und hab ich mir eben runtergeladen. Da hab ich erst mal so Leute auf Blind, hab ich einfach unter Suchoption Hobbies, LF2 gesucht. So, okay, einen Plan wurde ich nicht aufgenommen. Ja, ich hab da ein paar gute Freunde gefunden. Hab selbst einen Plan gegründet. Mit, das sind jetzt fünf Member. Immerhin. Ja, und mit diesen wirklich klasse Leute manche antworten irgendwie nicht. Die hab ich dann aus meiner Liste gelöscht. Und ich hab da einen sehr, sehr guten Freund. Und mit dem tät ich andauernd, wenn er online ist.
Das heißt, du chattest nur? Ja. Also du benutzt nichts anderes?
Doch, Casa und so.
Oder was? Was? Ja, gut, aber das ist jetzt nicht unbedingt. Also das ist im weitesten ein Austausch.
Das ist ein Dateiaustauschgewohnheit, würden wir dich jetzt nicht befragen. Aber hast du denn auch jetzt an einem von diesen neuen Social Networks teilgenommen, wo es explizit darum geht, sozusagen über Freunde von Freunden, andere Freunde kennenzulernen?
Nee, das mache ich nicht. Also ich habe von diesem Freund, er hat mir ein paar Kontakte gegeben. Und das sind eigentlich, er kennt eigentlich nur gute Leute, so nette Leute. Und die sind überhaupt nicht unfreundlich. Und wenn man ein Problem hat, helfen die auch einem. Und ja, das ist ganz anders als in der Realität. Da kann ich mit Leuten nicht so gut umgehen.
Ach so. Das heißt, das...
Und die haben da auch gar keine Vorurteile und so.
Das heißt, es wird auch für dich sicherlich das Wachsen des Social Networking ja auch ein Kommunikationsgewinn sein?
Naja, ich weiß nicht. Es entwickelt sich alles irgendwie so anders. Ich meine, der Chat wurde auch nur deswegen geschlossen, weil über 1000 Mitglieder waren. Und da waren noch Spam und Flooding. Und überall haben die nur für was anderes geworben. Und ja, deswegen wurde ja auch geschlossen.
Was meinst du denn damit, dass du in der Realität da nicht so gut kommunizieren kannst?
Ja, ich weiß nicht. Vielleicht liegt es an meinem Äußeren. Ich trinke eine Brille und bin recht klein.
Das hörst du nicht, dass da mal nichts Stimmes?
Naja, kommt noch an, wo man lebt. Na ja, meine Umgebung finde ich nicht gerade so angenehm.
Charlottenburg?
Nein, ich wohne in Charlottenburg. Meine Schule ist in Wilmersdorf. Im Gymnasium, aber ich finde meine Klassenmitglieder nicht so toll.
Na gut, das sind Probleme, die sich dann auch irgendwann legen.
Also, das sind alles ganz nette Leute. Ich hatte da eigentlich ganz gute Erfahrungen. Und ja, dieses Main-Chat, das ist wirklich eine gute Sache, außer dass es sehr viel Speicher eben einnimmt. Ich hab da auch früher einen eigenen Chat gehabt. Der wurde dann aber geschlossen. Ja, wenn 90 Tage niemand draufgeht, dann wird der automatisch geschlossen. Dann nehme ich einen kostenloser Dienst und jetzt habe ich wieder einen. Und da habe ich jetzt auch eine Domäne. Das war eine irre lange Adresse. Das habe ich dann nicht aufgehalten.
Schreib sie ins Fritz-Bord, wenn du sie beteilen willst. Manuel, wir danken für deinen Anruf.
Und noch was? Ab wann darf man da so aufgenommen werden? Ich interessiere mich wirklich sehr für Programmierungen. Das mache ich auch zu Hause.
Na ja, also eigentlich haben wir da keine Beschränkungen.
Bleib mal dran. Bleib einfach mal dran. Wir spielen jetzt wieder eine kleine Musik, wo es um Freunde geht und dann erklären wir dir alles, wie es geht. Das ist ein ganz schöner Film. Das ist ein ganz schöner Film. Das ist ein ganz schöner Film. Das ist ein ganz schöner Film. Das ist ein ganz schöner Film.
Das ist ein ganz schöner Film.
Das ist ein ganz schöner Film. Das ist ein ganz schöner Film. Das ist ein ganz schöner Film.
Ich hab mich da so von klein auf bis hoch gekämpft, sozusagen. Und daraus ist jetzt so ein bisschen entstanden, so eine, naja ich sag mal, IRC-Beschäftigung, wo sich denn alle so treffen und durchaus auch normal miteinander reden, ohne dass es alles unbedingt überhandelt geht, sondern auch mal den eigenen Namen zu verraten. Das ist alles relativ offen dort und ich glaube, wir haben dort alle wenig Probleme mit Datenschutz, ist vertraut, uns alle gegenseitig, soweit das irgendwie schon funktioniert.
Das ist aber auch nicht von außen einsehbar.
Na ja, die Informationen, die da drin stehen, sind doch noch limitiert. Also ich sag mal, man könnte da sicherlich kein psychologisches Profil von demjenigen anfangen, den gerade Weihe sich um technisches Thema handelt und die meisten da irgendwie doch ihre Informationen drauf beziehen. Aber wenn man halt so Signaturen oder so anschaut, dann sind ja dort auch Lebenseinstellungen in irgendeiner Form drin. Wenn man mal in so einem Forum war, kennt man das ja.
Ja, zum Thema Data Mining habe ich da gerade eine lustige News-Ränge reingereicht bekommen. Und zwar die Leute von quintis.org in Österreich. Die haben sich den Spaß gemacht, die haben das komplette Archiv einer von der NSA, also dem amerikanischen elektronischen Abhörgernahmendienst betriebenen Biometrie-Mailing gestipped von 1994 bis 2004, 12, 3 MB SIPFAL, runtergeladen und haben dann sich eine Genehmigung vom österreichischen Datenschutz-Beauftragten geholt, um auch mal Data-Mailing zu betreiben, das heißt also mal die Profile zu onnen und dann Profile zu erstellen und Networks zu erstellen und so weiter und so fort haben die Genehmigung auch bekommen. Das heißt, sie dürfen die Daten verarbeiten und haben dann halt eine Notiz nach europäischem Datenschutzrecht auf dieser Mailing-Liste gepostet, dass sie das halt tun werden und sich halt da Profilanalysen machen und mal gucken, wer bei der NSA wer ist und so weiter und so fort. Und ja, und da meinten sie, das sehe ich schon ganz interessant aus. Irgendwann die Server von denen kurz offline und den Listen-Moderator meinte, da würden jetzt wohl Schritte unternommen werden, aber jetzt sind sie wohl wieder online.
Das finde ich übrigens das Lustige daran. Also bei allerlieber zu paranoia. Es ist ein Unterschied, ob ich ausgespitzelt werde und ob ich irgendwie keine Kontrolle habe über das, was über mich erfasst wird oder ob ich selbstbestimmt an die Sache rangehe und sage, ich gebe jetzt das ein, was ich verantworten kann und dann habe ich für mich ein Data-Mining-Tool, was sonst nur die Großen haben, nur die bösen Jungs. Und das kann ich jetzt mal benutzen. Finde ich schon sehr interessant.
Das habe ich nicht verstanden.
Also um diese Systeme, die sonst halt nur Geheimdiensten oder so zugänglich sind oder sehr sehr großen Firmen, Data-Mining, wo man dann halt einfach alle Daten mal sammelt und dann Verknüpfungen herstellt, wo eigentlich vorher keine bestanden usw. An die kommt man ja erstmal zum Spielen nicht ran.
Das stimmt.
Richtig. Bei Orkut, wo alles offen ist, wo ich meine Sachen reingehen kann, kann ich dann auch anfangen und selber Data Mining betreiben. Ein Bekannter von mir hat dann auch, da waren wir alle so zwei Tage auf Orkut, hat er angefangen, ein Perlmodul zu schreiben, wo man jetzt halt auch selber Data Mining betreiben kann, wo man halt auch gucken kann, wer es mit wem verknüpft oder das ganze System einfach mal nach Singles durchsuchen kann oder nach Leuten, die die gleichen Hobbys haben und so. Ich finde das schon wichtig, sich mit solchen Sachen auch auseinanderzusetzen und dann nicht irgendwie so einen Beißreflex zu haben und zu sagen, neue Technologie, das hat irgendwas mit Überwachung zu tun. Überwachung, ausspitzeln ist eine schlimme Sache. Das heißt aber nicht, dass man mit großen Datenmengen nicht irgendwie auch dann Erfahrungen sammeln muss.
Gab es doch nicht sowieso schon immer solche Suchmaschinen, wo man, also getarnt als, haben zur selben Zeit den Abschluss gemacht, man sowieso danach suchen konnte, nach bestimmten Personen und durchaus auch was gefunden hat? Wenn man das dann mit Daten von, was ist ich, Google, oder dementsprechenden Suchmaschinen kombiniert, kriegt man noch von den relativ meisten ein ganz gutes Profil eigentlich hin.
Ja, klar ist das so. Die Frage ist halt, bei diesen Communities hat man sozusagen den Vorteil, aber auch den Nachteil, dass man bewusst entscheiden muss, was man angibt. Also die Beziehung zu wem man halt preisgibt, also ob man sagt, okay, mit dem habe ich was zu tun, ob man sagt, okay, das lehne ich mal ab und sage ihm hinterher noch, na, Kneipe, ich hab dich abgelehnt, weil ich irgendwie nicht möchte, dass man weiß, dass ich mit dir irgendwie zusammenhänge. Oder ob man sagt, okay, ich gebe halt nur an, was ohnehin schon über mich bekannt ist. Oder also wie man damit tatsächlich mit umgeht. Also wie sieht die Informationshygiene in solchen Social Networking Software Geschichten aus? Ich glaube, das ist eine Sache, die wir halt einfach in den nächsten Jahren lernen müssen. Auf den Mailinglisten ist es ja so, also ich hab neulich zum Geburtstag eine CD geschenkt bekommen mit all meinen Schandtaten aus dem CL Netz von Anfang der 90er Jahre. Das war durchaus amüsant und interessant zu sehen. Hat mir auch irgendwie einige Kopfschmerzen genommen, weil ich mich an einigen Mails nicht mehr so genau erinnern konnte, was ich da geschrieben habe. Dann konnte ich es dann nachlesen und sehen, dass es überhaupt gar nicht so schlimm war. Aber genau dieses ewige Liste Problem, was im Internet ist, ist halt einfach da. Und gerade Mailinglisten werden halt archiviert. Und gehen halt nicht weg. Und lassen sich halt nunfalls auch 10 Jahre, 20 Jahre, 30 Jahre oder 40 Jahre später noch nachvollziehen. Macht euch nichts vor, wir werden alle noch im Altersheim Internet haben.
Oder das Nachfolge.
Und dann haben wir halt einfach mal, jeder von uns hat dann einfach mal so 50, 60, 70 Jahre Datenspuren auf dem Buckel.
Ich war letztens auch ganz erstaunt, dass ich hier auf der Online-Seite meines Gymnasiums tatsächlich meinen Abschluss gefunden habe. Und auch noch eine digitale Kopie der Schulzeitung, sodass man also die ganze Seite ganz hervorragend dadurch scannen konnte und durchaus relativ viel über meine Abi-Zeit rausgefunden hat. Ganz erstaunlich, ich hab's nie gesagt, dass das gerne mal passieren darf. Oder zumindest nicht, dass ich mich dran erinnere.
Dann müssen wir uns jetzt alle irgendwie... Aber so neu ist das eigentlich nicht. Datenspuren gibt's auch schon vor dem Internet.
Die Verfügbarkeit ist eine andere.
Im Filonet hat jeder auch schon Spuren hinterlassen, der mal drin war.
Es gibt auch einen deutschen Außenminister, von dem es Datenspuren gibt in Form von Fotos, wo er auf Polizisten losgeht.
Wo es aussieht, als ob er auf Polizisten losgeht.
Also deswegen wird das ja auch irgendwie von der jetzigen Regierung propagiert. Mut zu den Brüchen in der Biografie. Also wir werden alle irgendwie ganz, ganz viele Brüche in der Biografie haben.
Ja, weil wir ständig verknackt werden, ne? Das ist doch überhaupt nichts, äh...
Was ist denn, Polizeifotof?
Nein, nein, die Sache mit dem Schaf. Das wissen ja die wenigsten.
Ach du und das Schaf?
Nein, nicht nur ich.
Ach du und...
Nicht nur ich und nicht nur das. Aber das müssen wir jetzt nicht erratern, das kommt ja eh bald raus.
Ein Multi-User Schaf.
Ja, Schafe explodieren und machen maximal 50 Schaden.
Wir wünschen dir auch eine gute Nacht. Ich hoffe... Tim, such doch mal das Lied raus, was du jetzt spielen wolltest. Ich mach jetzt gerade mal... Ich lass jetzt mal jemand...
Wir spielen jetzt mal ein Lied.
Ja, Moment, ich lass jetzt mal jemanden ansagen, wie die Sendung heißt. Und dann...
Spielen wir den Orkut Song.
Genau.
Genau. Genau, Mitternacht, Chaosradio 89. Und Social Networking ist unser Thema.
Hey everybody, let's sing the Orkut Song. To discuss the food they eat. Maybe with a little luck they could find someone to have fun with. So let's make a lot of friends. Orkut's great, it's real inspired. Sign back in just like a squirrel. Good song. Everybody.
Passend zu diesem Lied gibt's neulich auf, es gibt einen Franz-Fleur-Berg-Café, das heißt, lass uns Freunde bleiben.
Echt? Bei mir um die Ecke gibt's einen Café, das heißt Liebling des Monats.
Und lassen sie dich da rein?
Ja, zumindest haben sie mich noch nicht rausgespüsen, was ja ungefähr so viel heißt wie lassen sie mich, ist ja auch egal. Chaosradio 89 ist hier in Social Networking das Thema am Telefon 033 171 97 110, der Mario, hallo Mario.
Ja, nee, das ist eine schlechte Übertragung momentan bei mir, tut mir leid. Ich hab gar kein Radio an.
Na dann leg mal los.
Ja, nee, ich wollte bloß sagen, ich war so ein, einer der Typen, der mal irgendwie nachts besoffen aus der Disco kam und im Internet so ein bisschen rumgesucht hat und dann irgendwie bei neu.de gelandet ist. Ja, ich gebe jetzt leider zu, ich bin so einer. Und war eigentlich eine feine Sache. Ich muss sagen, ich habe meine Freundin da kennengelernt.
Über lang oder kurz.
Und na gut, die Beziehung ist jetzt gestern kaputt gegangen.
Entschuldigung, über lang oder kurz, ist das eine Rubrik?
Nein.
Ach so, okay, Entschuldigung, ich hab jetzt, ich war jetzt irgendwie an der falschen Holga. Kümmern ihr euch mal um die Säle, um mich nach meinem Husten.
Wie hast du die jetzt kennengelernt?
Naja, also ich sag mal, der Vorteil an diesem System ist eigentlich, man hat eine Visitenkarte, wo man von sich aus eigentlich alle möglichen Sachen eintragen kann, ob es nur ein Hobbys sind oder weiß ich nicht was.
Plusbilder von einem selber.
Und naja, durch Suchmaschinen, weiß ich nicht, Bezirke oder weiß ich nicht, Hobbys, kann man sich dann halt irgendwelche Leute suchen, die zu einem passen.
Sie mich.
Und weißt du auch über welche Suchkriterien?
Das habe ich sie niemals gefragt, aber dazu ist jetzt nun auch leider zu spät.
Hast du dein Profil schon geändert?
Nein, ich habe es niemals geändert. Auch nicht währenddessen.
Das heißt du warst immer Single?
Gebe ich leider zu.
Allerdings muss ich sagen, was halt natürlich nachteilig ist, dass die männliche Bevölkerung dafür bezahlen muss.
20 Euro oder sowas, ne?
Ja genau, kommt darauf an, wie lange man das halt machen möchte. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Also im Endeffekt ist man sich zum Schluss eigentlich zu belicht dafür, dass man sagt, jetzt hab ich es doch schon. Also ich hab es nicht nötig, jemanden über sowas kennenzulernen. Aber sagen wir mal so, es ist für einen Single ein schöner Selbstläufer. Einfach mal nach der Arbeit mal kurz da reingucken, ob sich jemand gemeldet hat oder sich selber irgendwo melden. Und man hat echt gute Erfolge.
Klappt denn sowas? Also auf Orkut ist das Verhältnis Männer zu Frauen 5 zu 1.
Ja, wie das Verhältnis ist, kann man eigentlich da eigentlich gar nicht so überprüfen. Aber ich denke mal, dass auf jeden Fall auch viel mehr Männer als Frauen da sind. Aber es läuft. Also ich meine, wenn man ein gutes Foto hat, was so ein bisschen anlockt, was die Frauen anspricht, dann hat man auf jeden Fall gute Chancen.
War das in deinem Fall so?
Nee, das ist jetzt hier glaube ich der falsche Ort.
Was meinst du, was würde funktionieren?
Ganz hypothetisch selbstverständlich.
Also theoretisch?
Es kommt immer drauf an, was für Frauen man ansprechen möchte. Die einen, die sagen natürlich, wenn einer mit freiem Oberkörper irgendwie rumsteht, das ist mir zu protzig, mit so einem will ich nicht zu tun haben.
Mist.
Oder halt die neue Anleitung. Mein lieber Jens, bist du ohnehin verheiratet? Ich aber nicht.
Lass dich nicht unterbrechen von Holger, bitte. Ich finde sowas an sich schon eine gute Sache. Leute fürs Leben kennenzulernen kann ich mir überhaupt nicht vorstellen. Aber so für irgendwelche Lebensabschnitte, also Freunde vielleicht nicht unbedingt. Ich spiele jetzt Painful seit einiger Zeit. Da Leute zu finden, ist doch schon einfacher.
Obwohl es doch geht mit Leute fürs Leben, also zumindest für einen Teil des Lebens. Einen meiner besten Freunde habe ich Mitte der 90er im ERC kennengelernt. Wirklich? Tatsächlich.
Ja, es gibt überall Aufnahmen.
Ich sage hier für Lebensabschnitte bestimmt. Aber so die Frau fürs Leben, die wird man da bestimmt nicht finden.
Aber da kommt es ja auch ein bisschen drauf an, ob man sich riechen kann.
Will man ja vielleicht auch nicht, ne?
Naja, will man vielleicht auch gar nicht. Na gut.
Naja, für Paintball hat dann halt auch die Sache mit dem Freunde treffen, auch irgendwie eine ganz andere Bedeutung.
Ich straf sie zwischen den Augen.
Plakat vom Schützenverein schießen und Leute treffen fürs Schützenfest.
Naja, auf jeden Fall eine schöne Sache.
Mario, vielen Dank.
Kein Problem.
Und eine schöne Nacht noch.
Kannst du noch mal die tolle Rufnummer sagen? Ich muss hier auch mal in dieses Dokument reinschreiben.
Ja, nicht schlecht. Okay, bisschen Freund-Musik?
Und die Beatles.
Heißt das eigentlich With a little help from my friends? Wirklich der Titel von diesem Lied? Ja, Friends machen. Also ich meine, das ist ja auch, es gibt ja auch noch andere communities, in Anführungsstrichen, die Kontaktbedürfnis haben, und zwar ganz intensiven. Und zwar sind das die Leute mit dem begrenzten Sauerstoffzufuhr zum Hören.
Die Schlepsräger.
Warte, warte, warte, hier hat gerade mal kurz, kurzer Zwischenruf aus dem Auto, damit es nicht so teuer wird. Kloot?
Ja, hallo?
Du hast eine Frage.
Ja, und zwar höre ich euch jetzt eine ganze Weile zu und ich habe auch Internet, schon knapp ein Jahr oder was. Und da höre ich jetzt zum ersten Mal, ich meine, so kleine Foren kennt man ja, wo man so ein bisschen was reinschreibt, was ihr da so erzählt, hört sich ja ziemlich interessant an. Und dann wollte ich mal fragen, wo man solche, so was wie Orkuts, ich meine, das habe ich mir schon aufgeschrieben, wie kriegt man Informationen zu solchen Foren, Communities über eine Suchmaschine im Internet, ganz normal Google oder so?
Da schreibst du mal rein Social Networking oder soziales Netzwerken und das spuckt so viel aus, dass du erst mal eine Woche zu lesen hast.
Genau. Und dann, was noch eure Datenschutzprobleme da? Also, ich weiß nicht, selbst wenn man jetzt nicht über Internet auf einem ganz normalen Wege Leute kennenlernt, man erzählt ja auch nicht sofort sein ganzes Leben oder so. Ich mein, ich weiß ja nicht, was verlangen die denn jetzt diese ganzen Foren für Information von einem? Das ist doch einem selbst freigestellt, oder?
Ja, das ist sehr unterschiedlich, aber wie gesagt, der kritische Punkt ist, wie viel Information gibt man an? Versucht man sich möglichst interessant darzustellen und gibt halt mehr an, als man normalerweise angehen würde? Oder tritt halt genau diese hübsche Blondine interessiert mich Faktor auf und man erzählt alles von sich, was man lieber nicht erzählen sollte und so weiter und so fort? Das sind halt genau die kritischen Fragen, die wir da gerade diskutieren.
Und die Entscheidung nimmt einem keiner ab, erwachsen werden ist manchmal schwer.
Ja, ich sag, das ist ja natürlich jedem selbst überlassen, was er da preisgibt, oder? Und ich sag mal, schon rein die ganz normale Vorsicht, dass man da jetzt nicht beim ersten Mal sofort Adresse alles preisgibt, ist doch irgendwo logisch, ne?
Naja, es gibt ja noch Leute, die das tun.
Ja, warte, ich meine, geh in die nächste Kneipe und guck nach dem nächsten Betrunkenen und der erzählt ja auch genau alles.
Ja, obwohl, ich geh nicht ins Netz, wenn ich besoffen bin, oder? Ich meine, da komm ich ja schon an, mit der Tastatur nicht klar.
Och, da gibt's Leute.
Ich hab zu Hause noch ein ERC-Chatprotokoll von 1996, wo einer völlig besoffen sein RUT-Passwort geändert hat. Also, eigentlich ist es danach. Also dann hat er seine Dose angeschmissen, ist in Irk gekommen und hat rumgefragt, ob es irgendeinen Weg gibt, rauszufinden, was er für ein Passwort da eingegeben haben geheimte. Aber allein die Art und Weise zu schreiben, wie er besoffen war, das war ganz toll. Der eine Satz lautet ungefähr, erzählt das bloß nicht weiter. Dafür braucht er aber ungefähr dreimal so viele Buchstaben, um das zu sagen. Und du musst dann einfach die redundanten Buchstaben rausstellen.
Dann euer Chaos Club, da habt ihr ja raffohlen so einen Jüngeren gehabt, der hat da irgendwelche Fragen zum Chaos Club gehabt. Ist das einfach nur eine Sendung im Radio oder gibt's da noch mehr?
Das ist der Chaos Computer Club, www.ccc.de und der Chaos Computer Club macht am letzten Mittwoch im Monat eine Sendung im Radio jeweils.
Alles klar, dann bedanke ich mich, das war's schon und ja, ich werd weiter zuhören. Dankeschön.
Und ein Anruf aus Hamburg.
Na, wie schaut's?
Wie immer.
Ich wollte mal ein bisschen zurück aufs Thema. Ich meine, es ist so schön, dass wir alle Foren kennen und Chats und auch ICQ sogar schon. Social Networks finde ich ziemlich spannend, aber es ist eben doch ein bisschen mehr als einfach nur eine Partnersuchbörse, wo man irgendwie sein Profil angibt und hofft, dass man gefunden wird. Sondern ich finde eben Sachen wie Orkut, da habt ihr noch in Fluss drüber geredet, oder eben was sich Open BC, den Open Business Club, schon ziemlich spannend. Es gibt ja in Deutschland auch dieses Friendity und den amerikanischen Friendstar. Und das ist ja schon ein bisschen was anderes als eine einfache Partnersuchmaschine. Weil hier geht es darum, dass man Netzwerke knüpft und über die Netzwerke versucht, irgendwie Leute zu finden. Ähnlich wie im realen Leben, dass du irgendwie jemanden oder meistens nur kennenlernst, wenn du über irgendwie Freunde von ihm kommst. Und das ist der Unterschied zwischen Neu.de oder anderen Partnerbörsen und den Social Networks.
Du bringst uns jetzt endlich mal in die Richtung dieser Business Networks. Eines hast du ja schon genannt, dieses OpenBC, was halt in Deutschland entsteht, tatsächlich in Hamburg. Die meisten sind ja eigentlich aus Amerika. Ich weiß nicht, fallen dir jetzt so prompt noch andere deutsche Business Networks ein?
Nö. Also ich meine es gibt in Amerika dieses LinkedIn und TribeNet.
Rise?
Ja genau. Aus meiner Warte macht das keinen Sinn, da großartig teilzunehmen, weil die meisten ja Amis sind. Und die überstaunen sind dann doch eher selten. Dieser Open Business Club in Deutschland ist eigentlich schon eine ganz vernünftige Lösung. Vor allem weil er relativ offen ist, finde ich jedenfalls.
Offen wofür?
Naja, er gibt relativ wenig vor. Das heißt, du kannst deine ganzen Themen, die du wichtig findest, selber in einer freien Form eingeben. Das finde ich eigentlich schon ganz nett.
Und wofür benutzt du das und wo sie konkreten Nutzen vor allem drin?
Ich benutze es vor allem, um irgendwie mit Leuten in Kontakt zu bleiben, die man irgendwie schon mal von irgendwoher gekannt hat. Und dann sieht man, wie die noch so alles kennen. Und da kann man schon ganz nett in Kontakt zu knüpfen.
Eigentlich kennt man ja nun das Business eigentlich immer so, dass die Kontakte so in gewisser Hinsicht das Wertvollste sind, was man hat. Was denkst du, ist denn eigentlich das, was die Leute dazu bringen, dieses Wertvollste quasi kostenlos im Netz zu dokumentieren?
Und die Frage, die sind wir auch schon häufiger gestellt.
Nicht so sehr das Business-Modell des Betreibers der Webseite, sondern eigentlich erstmal, was ist sozusagen für mich oder dich als Teilnehmer der Anreiz, das zu tun?
Ja, das ist schon das Business-Modell des Betreibers, weil es liegt ja wirklich in dessen Interesse, dass du dorthin gehst, dafür Geld bezahlst und dann auch noch deine Kontakte preisgibst.
Ach, das kostet auch noch was.
Ja sicher, also wenn du es wirklich nutzen willst, dann kostet, keine Ahnung, es kostet irgendwie 6, 7 Euro oder sowas. Und nur dann klappt auch wirklich die Kontaktaufnahme.
Hattest du schon Erfolg über OpenBC?
Ja.
Das heißt, du hast Kunden gefunden oder hast irgendwas billiger bekommen oder so?
Also ich habe auf alle Fälle Kontakte gefunden und interessante Gespräche geführt, ja. Und ein, zwei andere Sachen sind auch schon zustande gekommen. Also ich finde das ganz praktisch.
Was kriege ich denn dafür, wenn ich mich einfach nur kostenlos registriere bei OpenBC?
Meine Güte, ich bin jetzt hier nicht der Pressesprecher von OpenBC.
Hätte ja sein können. Du sagtest, das kostet Geld.
Keine Ahnung, ich glaube, wenn du kostenlos bist, dann kannst du das 30 Tage lang komplett nutzen. Und danach wird es eingeschränkt.
Ach so.
Dann fällt irgendwie eine Suchfunktionalität weg, die ja schon relativ wichtig ist.
Genau. Also nach dem Modell arbeiten halt auch die anderen, so rise.com und so. Und die haben wohl auch teilweise schon ziemlich große Listen von Leuten, die halt wirklich dafür Geld bezahlen. Also groß ist natürlich für so eine, man braucht ja eigentlich nicht viel, um so ein System zu betreiben, das ist ja im Prinzip nur ein Server mit genug Bandbreite. Also das ist nicht wirklich viel. Man braucht eigentlich auch noch nicht mal besonders viel Programmierer für so einfache Suchfunktionen. Dass vergleichsweise kleine Firmen dann doch schon recht großen Kundenstamm haben. Und wenn da irgendwie 25.000 Leute 10 Dollar zahlen, dann kommt da schon eine Menge bei rum. Und jetzt noch mal zur Motivation. Gibt es auch Kontakte, die du sozusagen nicht preisgeben würdest, weil du dich dafür schämst? Oder die als nicht kontaktwürdig hältst?
Ich lösche überall aus meiner Kontaktliste erst mal Tim Fridler raus, weil das mir echt peinlich ist.
Report as bogus.
Siehst du das als Empfehlung? Oder siehst du das als Tipp? Oder hilft man sozusagen seinen Kontakten dadurch, dass man sie erwähnt? Oder ist das einfach nur, ach ich schmeiß mal alle rein, die ich kenne. Und wenn das alle anderen auch tun, habe ich da auch was von.
Ich sehe das schon so, dass ich da eher die Leute anfüge, für die das auch selber Sinn macht. Ich meine, du musst ja die Leute einladen und sie müssen auch mitmachen, sonst bringt das ja nix. Da sollte schon eine gewisse Affinität zu irgendwelchen Online-Medien da sein. Die sollten schon irgendwie so ein bisschen federfrei im Internet umhergehen können.
Im Chat, der hier gerade auch ein bisschen durchscrollt, hat jemand dann auch noch eine Erfolgsstory. Also der hat über OpenBC einen Schuldner wiedergefunden.
Dann melde ich mich da mal lieber nicht an.
Ja, hast du sonst noch irgendwelche Dinge, auf die du uns stoßen möchtest?
Ja, also eine Sache, die ich ihm relativ spannend fände, wäre, wenn man das ganze Thema Social Network mal dezentral anpacken würde.
Oh ja.
Das hatte ich auch schon in dem SubEtherEdit-Ding geschrieben, eine Verknüpfung von FOF, also Friend of a Friend, zum Beispiel mit Java.
Erklär das mal für blöde bitte, ich bin blöd.
Ja gut, also Friend of a Friend ist eine XML-Spitze, mit der du sagen kannst, wer du bist und wen du kennst. Und das ist eben maschinendienstbar, und so kann man quasi diese Freundeskreise auch abbilden, aber eben ohne, dass man direkt bei einem Anbieter sich irgendwie registrieren muss. Und meine Idee wäre eben, wenn man das mit Java verknüpft, was ein hoffnendes Instant-Messaging-Protokoll ist, dass man dann vielleicht eine dezentrale Lösung hinbekommt für so ein Social Network, und eben nicht mehr an einen Anbieter gebunden ist.
Ja, also ich hab viel Hass mir entgegen geschlagen, als ich angefangen habe, Leute auf Orkut einzuladen. Viele aus meiner Peer Group, die dann irgendwie meinten, warum lädst du mich zu den Datenkraken ein, etc. Aber eine Sache ist mir noch echt im Kopf geblieben. Eine junge Frau, die dann irgendwie meinte, als sie das zum ersten Mal gesehen hat, verdammt, warum sind wir nicht auf die Idee gekommen? Warum muss Google das machen? Warum machen wir das nicht irgendwie in cool, in open source, in dezentral und mit anständiger Krypto? Und warum macht ihr es nicht? Die Lethargie, die Verpeilung, denke ich mal.
Google hat ein bisschen mehr Kohle in der Tasche als wir beide. Und insofern denke ich, dass es bei Google einfach ein ganz nettes Nebenprodukt ist.
Es gab ja schon relativ viele Ansätze, es zu versuchen. Also ich hab 1999 auch irgendwie eine Firma angefangen mit ziemlich genau so einem Ansatz. Und das Problem war einfach zu früh. Und es gibt halt keinen guten Weg damit wirklich Geld zu verdienen bisher. Aber wenn du es halt richtig machen willst, sagen wir mal irgendwie ohne Liturgie und mit Leuten, die halt irgendwie da kontinuierlich daran arbeiten, führt halt kein Weg drum herum, dass du wenigstens ein Quarteam bezahlst. Und das führt halt in der Regel dazu, dass du sowas wie ein Businessmodell brauchst. Das ist halt das Problem dabei. Und selbst wenn du anfängst, es nur sozusagen als reines Open Source Projekt, als GNU-Projekt zu machen, wo du halt einfach nur mit freiwilligen Programmierern arbeitest, brauchst du halt eine gewisse Struktur, einen gewissen Support, der halt irgendwie organisiert ist. Und das ist letztendlich dann das Problem, dass du so lange mit solchen Sachen kein Geld machen kannst. Du hast entweder solche Leute wie Google, die sich halt leisten können, Spielvise zu betreiben, oder halt naja, solche Commerzportale wie halt neu.de oder ähnliche Leute, die halt dann tatsächlich irgendwie versuchen, Geld damit zu verdienen, dass sie dir Mitgliederbeiträge abknüpfen.
Ja, aber vermisch das doch bitte nicht immer. Also neu.de ist wirklich kein Social Network. In keinster Weise, das ist einfach nur eine Partnersuppe. Also genauso wie Friends Code 24, wie die heißen. Oder wie Finja oder Singledy oder MyFlirt.
Ja klar, das sind halt die Primitivmodelle, die halt irgendwie so aussehen, als würden sie Geld abwerfen.
Ja, aber es geht bei der Sendung um Social Networks und da kommt kein Network zustande, sondern du gibst einfach ein Kriterium ein, bei der Suche um Christian rausgespuckt. Das ist aber noch keine große...
Ja, das ist richtig. Ja, bloß wie gesagt, dieses Networking an sich, da braucht man halt einfach auch eine ökonomische Basis für. Ich meine, Open BC zu sagen, okay, 10 Euro, und der Service ist interessant genug, dass man halt irgendwie die 10 Euro abdrückt pro Monat, ist halt irgendwie das erste Mal, dass ich sehe, dass so ein Ding irgendwie irgendeine Art von ökonomischer Basis bekommt, die irgendwie, sagen wir mal, tragfähig aussieht. So bei Orkut ist es halt, naja, Gott ist halt irgendwie Google und die haben halt irgendwie die Kohle im Zweifel, spätestens nach ihrem Börsengang.
Man, hast du denn eine gute These, was eigentlich Google mit Orkut wirklich im Sinne hat? Ich meine, darüber gibt es ja eine breite Diskussion und...
Ja klar, die habe ich. Die werden das versuchen, was DoubleClick vor ein paar Jahren mal versucht hat, nämlich die Verknüpfung von User-Profilen. Aus dem Offline- und Onlinebereich. Dafür DoubleClick ziemlich eins in die Fresse bekommen. Und das versucht Google jetzt auf eine etwas geschickte Weise zu machen.
Das ist ja ehrlich gesagt auch meine Hoffnung. Deswegen habe ich ja auch mein Profil so explizit angegeben, weil ich hoffe, dass ich in Zukunft dann halt targeted Spam nur noch über französische Literatur und asiatisches Essen bekomme. Und nicht mehr Penisverlängerungen.
Ja, gut.
Dank mal erst mal für deinen Beitrag.
Alles klar.
Wenn Fritz in der Friednis, dann 103, 1, eine nach halb eins.
Die Ärzte, meine Freunde im Chaosradio 89, in dem es auch um Freunde geht, nämlich um Social Networking. Soll ich weiterquatschen oder möchte vielleicht einer von den Herrschaften, die sich mit den Dingen auskennen? Ich soll Unsinn erzählen?
Nein, nein, nein, das hat da jetzt schon gereicht.
Freunde hast du denn schon? Sieben. Inklusive dir mein lieber Frank. Und?
Ja, also mit diesen Freundes-Dingern, da gibt es ja auch so diverse Mythen. Zum Beispiel gibt es diesen Mythos, dass es ja so sei, dass man ja jeden auf diesem Planeten kennen würde, über sechs Freunde, über sechs Ecken. Das hält sich, aber kann wohl eher als Legend gedeutet werden.
Stimmt es jetzt? Das ganze kommt von einem Paper, das 1976 rausgekommen ist. Also das hat dieser Psychologe Milgram gemacht. Den kennt man über das Milgram-Experiment, wo man Elektroschocks bestraft. Und der hat halt auch ein anderes Experiment gemacht, wo er Leuten gesagt hat, Leute, die in Kansas sitzen, liefert bei einer Ehefrau von einem Studenten von mir einen Brief ab, aber nur persönlich, gibt das weiter an andere Leute, wo er denkt, die Kette würde dann weitergehen. Das hat er an 60 Leute geschickt. 50 davon haben geantwortet, haben gesagt, okay, ich habe das weitergegeben, 10 erstmal unter den Tisch gefallen. Angekommen von den Briefen sind drei. Das heißt, er hat eine Erfolgsquote von 5 Prozent gehabt. Was dann in der Presse immer groß rausgestellt worden ist, ist, dass einer von diesen Briefen schon in vier Tagen und über total wenige Hops angekommen ist. Er hat dann noch weitere Experimente veranstaltet und da waren die Daten dann halt so schlecht, dass die gar nicht mehr veröffentlicht wurden.
Für die Bild-Zeitung hat es gereicht.
Na, was halt auch irgendwie bei rausgekommen ist, ist, dass die Daten dann halt auch irgendwie wieder schlechter werden, wenn zum Beispiel man einem Schwarzen, in dem Fall war das, diesen Brief gibt und die Zielperson war weiß. Das heißt, es musste irgendwie eine Community-Überlagpunkt da sein, wo das halt irgendwie hervorragend funktioniert. Das sind Communities, die relativ eng gestrickt sind. Es gibt einen Film, der heißt Six Degrees of Kevin Bacon und da wird halt behauptet, alle Schauspieler sind nur sechs Händeschüttelaktionen von Kevin Bacon entfernt. Und ist es so? Das ist wohl tatsächlich so. Also bei Gruppen, die untereinander dann noch einen regen Kontakt haben, sind diese Average-Pars oder diese Verbindungen dann sehr, sehr gering. Und das sehen wir bei Orkut halt auch. Das ist halt eine Geek-Community. Da laden Technik-Freunde, ihre anderen Technik-Freunde ein und dann sind wir alle irgendwie miteinander verbunden. Aber als Modell für die gesamte Welt ist das wohl eher eine Urban Legend, ja.
Interessant finde ich schon dieses Spiel, was man ja so auf Party spielt, wenn man da getrunken ist und Langeweile hat und sich rausstellen soll, wie wichtig die Leute sind. Dass man so Spiele spielt, so wieviel mal Hände schütteln, dass man von irgendeiner wichtigen Person entfacht. Und mit geschickter Auswahl der wichtigen Person sind es tatsächlich verbürgend wenige mal Hände schütteln. Das bei Orkut ja auch immer so dieses Problem ist, dass man bei diesen anderen Friend-Networks dieses Briefmarken sammelt. Also dass man halt einfach wichtige oder semi-wichtige Persönlichkeiten oder Stars oder was auch immer da sammelt. Neulich habe ich ein interessantes Spiel kennengelernt, was in Japan wohl so halbwegs verbreitet ist. Es funktioniert so, die beiden Mitspieler packen ihr Mobiltelefon aus und suchen sich jeweils eine Mobiltelefonnummer raus und sagen von wem die ist. Und derjenige, der die wichtigere hat, hat sozusagen diese Runde gewonnen und der andere muss seine löschen.
Achso, das heißt du packst jetzt deins aus und sagst Tim Prittlaff. Ich pack meins aus und sage Gerhard Schröder Bundeskanzler.
Das ist ja eigentlich ein geiles Spiel. Das ist die Panzerquartett.
Ja, das ist besser als gerade und gerade um den Szenar.
Die Japanerin, die mir das gezeigt hat, und mit der ich das noch eine Weile gespielt hab, war sehr lustig. Die war dann ein bisschen enttäuscht, als sie erzählt hat, dass ich Backups mache.
Das ist echt super, das kann man mit Bekifften gut machen. Weil die kannst du so super verarschen. Warum ist das, jetzt muss ich ja schon wieder meine Nummer löschen. Kennt ihr das berühmte Namensags-Spiel?
Also es gibt bei den Mathematikern auch noch so etwas wie diese Kevin-Bacon-Geschichte. Das ist die Erdos-Number, also nach dem ungarischen Mathematiker Paul Erdos, der halt in seinem ganzen Leben über 1500 Papiere, also so Artikel in Fachzeitschriften veröffentlicht hat, meistens mit Co-Autoren. Und er selber hat die Erdos-Number Null und wer halt irgendwie mit ihm ein Papier zusammen veröffentlicht hat, hat dann eine Nummer von eins und man wird dann halt in der Mathematiker-Community halt entsprechend gerenkt. Je geringer die Erdos-Number ist, je näher man an dieser Person dran ist.
Ich dachte Wissenschaftler wären vor so was gefeilt.
Nee, die machen auch Orkuts.
Es gibt ja SideSeeker, das ist von NEC, so eine Wissenschaftswebseite, wo sie halt wissenschaftliche Papers sammeln und die haben halt auch einen Citation Index, also wo sie gucken, wer zitiert von wem und wie oft und da werden Papers halt richtig geringt danach, wie oft diese Papers zitiert werden und wann sie zuletzt zitiert wurden und so weiter und so fort, also das ist ganz hart.
Wie ist die Seite?
Sidesieger, NEC, COJJP, war nicht so...
Guck mal, guck die Nachwandschrift ins Dokument.
Bevor diese Sendung zu Ende geht, wollte ich übrigens noch einen Literatur-Tipp loswerden, den loszuwerden Tim mich gebeten hat. Es gibt demnächst ein neues Buch, hast du gesagt.
Du hältst es ja schon in der Hand.
Ich halte es schon in die Kamera. Nee, die Kamera ist da. Das ist schon erschienen oder was? Ich dachte, das wäre ein Rezensionsexemplar für dich.
Das ist es auch. Also es ist sozusagen jetzt in der Queue, das heißt Hardware Hacking Projects for Geeks.
Genau.
Also sowas wie du Holger, du bist doch der Geek. Das ist eine einschlägige E-Mail leider.
Da krieg ich ja auch nichts dafür.
Ich hab eine Brille, stimmt.
Ich hab keinen Schub, aber ich auch ein schönes Buch, wo es um allerlei Bastel Zeug geht, zum selber machen von eigener Stromversorgung für ein Laptop oder wie man aus dem Macintosh ein Aquarium baut, seine eigenen WLAN Antennen, irgendwie ein Wasserkühlungssystem für sein PC. Manche brauchen das ja oder ein Videopiriskop für das Auto, ein Videopiriskop fürs Auto.
Ja, das will ich.
Ja, das ist ganz toll.
Das ist auch alles sehr schön erklärt mit irgendwie, es fängt halt richtig an mit wie benutze ich einen Lötkolben und was sind so die standardmäßigen elektronischen Bauteile, also auch gerade für Leute, die sich sozusagen dem Thema Hardware-Baste als solchen nähern wollen, durchaus zu empfehlen. Uns freut natürlich besonders das Kapitel 8, How to Hack a Building Size Display, wo der junge Mann, wie heißt er noch gleich? Scott Fulham beschreibt, wie man Blinkenlites baut, hat also alle Pläne und auch lustige Fotos davon.
Weißen Themen Prittlove davon?
Keine Ahnung.
Aber es würde ihn bestimmt freuen, wenn er es wüsste.
Bestimmt. Und schön ist auch, dass wir sozusagen gleich Beispiele gegeben haben, wie man sich sozusagen seine kleine eigene Variante machen kann. Es gibt ja diverse Nachbauprojekte und auch das ist dann hier detailliert beschrieben. Ja, so viel zu Werbung in anderer und eigener Sache.
Keine Sendung ohne Blinken, Leitz. Wo wir bei den Geek-Themen sind.
Du bist schlimm, jetzt werde ich wieder geschlagen.
Wieso? Du hast doch gesagt, ich muss...
Genau deswegen werde ich geschlagen.
Und dann der Nachhaltiger wird bestimmt wieder Orkut-Punkte dafür haben.
Was genau?
Ich will Orkut.
Gibt es Orkut-Punkte?
Orkut-Punkte, also Eiswürfelchen und solche Sachen.
Oh, ich will Eiswürfelchen.
Oder Herzchen.
Ich glaube, ich verliere gerade den Verstand und merke es nicht, aber okay.
Wo wir gerade bei den Geek-Themen sind, man kann dieses ganze Ding mit den sozialen Netzwerken natürlich auch irgendwie weitaus geekiger angehen. Der Nico aus Hamburg, der gerade angerufen hat, hat da FOAF erwähnt. Das ist halt wie gesagt ein XML-Austauschformat, wo ich halt dann auch maschinenlesbar sagen kann, ich kenne diese Person oder mit einer Erweiterung kann man auch sagen, das ist mein Todfeind oder mit dieser Person bin ich verheiratet. Und entsprechende oder oder Unverknüpfungen dann halt auch noch feststellen.
Genau das, was bei Orkut fehlt.
Genau, das ist das, was bei Orkut fehlt vielleicht. Das ist die eine Theorie, dass man das vielleicht irgendwie ein bisschen filigraner haben möchte mit der Ordnung der Freundschaften in Orkut. Die andere Theorie, die ich auch relativ schlüssig finde, ist, wird da nicht das Gerangel darum anfangen, jetzt sei aber mein echter Freund oder nicht nur bekannter und ich weiß es nicht. Auf jeden Fall ist das auf jeden Fall ein Standard, der erst mal so definiert ist und den sollte man halt auch nehmen, weil er XML-basiert ist. Wir sollten sowieso nur Sachen nehmen, die XML-basiert sind.
Also er ist ja nicht nur XML-basiert, sondern für unsere gigigen Zuhörer kann man auch gleich erwähnen, er ist RDF-basiert, was wiederum XML-basiert ist. Das heißt, es ist alles ein Teil dieser Idee des semantischen Webs, des maschinenlesbaren Webs, in dem halt nicht nur Menschen eine Chance haben, den Inhalt von Webseiten zu begreifen, sondern eben auch Programme. Sozusagen Geheimdienst-Suchmaschinen freundlich. Was natürlich auch immer wieder die große Diskussion dahinter ist, also was passiert jetzt mit diesen Informationen, was ist mein persönliches Interesse daran, meine Freundschaftsbeziehungen, wie sie auch immer geartet sein sollen, zu publizieren?
Ist es überhaupt höflich, Leute in seinen FOAF-Profil aufzunehmen, ohne sie vorher gefragt zu haben? Oder publiziert man da nicht Sachen über Leute, die sich nicht wehren können? Aber zumindest eins von diesen sozialen Netzwerkgeschichten, TribeNet, wird jetzt in irgendeiner Form auch FOAF, also dieses XML-Format, nehmen. Das hieße dann für uns eigentlich, dass wir irgendwann dann nur noch mit irgendwelchen Tools unsere Beziehungsgeflechte zusammenklicken müssen und dann nicht uns heute bei Orkut, morgen bei TribeNet, übermorgen bei Friendster anmelden müssen und wieder diesen ganzen Sermon ausfüllen müssen. Sondern einfach, dass die Datei wird von meiner Homepage geladen und zack, irgendwie das Beziehungsgeflecht ist sichtbar.
Ich weiß aber nie, wer sie lädt.
Ja, das weiß man im Internet ja sowieso nie so richtig.
Da gibt es keine Möglichkeiten.
Was hätte hier sein können? Eine Frage...
Dass ich das noch irgendwie einschränken kann dann?
Ja, ich meine, es gibt halt Leute, die sagen irgendwie, nein, ich gebe meine Daten, auf keinen Fall preis. Und dann gibt es halt einfach Leute, die haben einfach gar nichts besseres zu tun, als genau das zu tun. Und auch mal die Frage, wie begegne ich sozusagen der drohenden Überwachung?
Ja, wer ist das mit dir? Du müsstest doch jetzt eigentlich aufgrund deiner persönlichen Vergangenheit vergleichsweise paranoid sein. Und wenn ich bei Orkut dein Profil lese, denke ich mir, ja, entweder bescheißt der hier oder der hat alles, was er bisher irgendwie für seine Werte gehalten hat, also seine ganze Paranoia über Bord geschmissen.
Was reitet dich? Tim war doch noch nie paranoid.
Ich bin nicht unbedingt jetzt für paranoider Sozokal.
Da hätte ich gedacht, der ist dann nicht für zuständig.
Da haben wir andere im Club.
Wir haben eine klare Umgangsteilung und Tims Aufgabensteilung ist nicht paranoid zu sein.
Das heißt, du musstest dich da gar nicht überwinden, das irgendwie zu machen.
Ja, das heißt, die Frage ist halt, lässt du das Web oder andere Datenbestände über dich was erzählen oder hältst du sozusagen mit eigener Propaganda dagegen? Und in dem Moment, wo ich irgendwie laut genug schreie, habe ich zumindest noch die Möglichkeit, meine eigene Sicht der Dinge darzulegen. Ob das nun die richtige Strategie ist, das einmal dahingestellt, es gibt sicherlich Leute, die ein bisschen mehr extrovertiert sind als introvertiert und für jeden gelten da eben andere Regeln und Parameter.
Also so ein leichtes Ungeruhlgefühl haben wir glaube ich alle bei diesen Geschichten. Also so ganz richtig wohl fühlen wir uns dabei nicht und wir können auch nur schwer abschätzen, was da in Zukunft passieren wird, aber wenn wir jetzt nicht dabei wären, dann würden wir auch ganz schön viel verpassen und das wollen wir halt nicht.
Also ich glaube, der Effekt ist so ein bisschen ähnlich, als es anfing, dass Leute Homepages hatten. Da gab es halt Leute, die hatten halt so, das ist meine Homepage und dann gab es so unterschiedliche Grade von Exhibitionismus. Da gibt es so diese klassischen Familien-Homepage, die einem einfach mehr sagen, als man jemals über irgendjemanden auch nur am Ansatz wissen wollte und irgendwie das Foto von der Frau und von den Kindern und noch mehr von den Kindern und von der Katze und von dem Haus von der Katze und irgendwie von dem Rasenhintermaus, den Formhaus und so weiter und so fort. Und dann gab es halt die Leute, die halt irgendwie sagen, naja Gott, ich habe ja keine Homepage, ich habe halt irgendwie nur meine Telefonnummer, wenn es hochkommt im Web. So und derselbe Effekt tritt eigentlich auch bei den Weblogs genau wieder auf. Es gibt halt Leute, die schreiben halt einfach genau alles. So und dann gibt es Leute, die schreiben halt nur eine relativ selektive Auswahl von dem, was sie so denken oder nur sehr thematisch eingegrenzt und so weiter und so fort. Und dann gibt es natürlich die Totblogs, die niemand interessiert. Und natürlich ist es immer so, dass der Voyeurismus natürlich zuschlägt. Also die Sachen, wo halt mehr über jemand zu erfahren ist, sind auch interessanter. Also da kriegt man halt in zweifel mehr Gummipunkte.
Es sei denn, derjenige kann gut schreiben.
Ja, es sei denn, derjenige kann wirklich gut schreiben. Genau so.
Und ich denke, ein ähnlicher Effekt tritt da halt auch bei Orkut auf. Andererseits bei Orkut natürlich immer noch der Bildaspekt dabei. Beziehungsweise bei den Social Networks, dass halt Bilder halt immer interessanter sind.
Also ich mach mir da schon Gedanken und Sorgen. Also ich hab eine kleine Seite über meine kleine Tochter und hab mir schon Gedanken gemacht, wie das ist, wenn sie dann später irgendwie dann Baby-Fotos im Google-Cache hat. Und hab diese Seite dann halt auch irgendwie für Google gesperrt. Das geht dann über so einen Robots-Text und die ist über Google nicht auffindbar. Weil ich denke, die aus meiner Familie, die diese Fotos gerne sehen wollen, denen geb ich die Adresse und alle anderen sollen das erstmal nicht sehen. Das muss er dann auch selbst entscheiden. Also das ist ja auch informationelle Selbstbestimmung und nicht immer Datenschutz, nicht immer Wegsperren, sondern selber bestimmen.
Also wie gesagt, diese Informationshygiene ist halt denke ich mal eine Sache, die wir einfach lernen müssen. Vermutlich wird es in der Schule darüber irgendwie wieder mal keine Unterrichtsstunden geben, so wenig wie es irgendwie über Internetunterrichtsstunden in der Schule gab. Das heißt, die Leute müssen es einfach durch Erfahrungen lernen. Oft genug ist es dann halt zu spät, weil irgendwie Google vergisst halt nicht, beziehungsweise das Internet an sich vergisst halt nicht. Wie gesagt, ich hab da eine Menge gelernt, als ich diese CD in die Hand bekam, mit meinen alten Jugendzünden, was dann doch auch am Anfang der 90er Jahre über mich erhalten ist in irgendwelchen Leuten.
Mut zu Brüchen in der Biografie.
Mut zur Inhaftierung. Ja, mitgeht Chaosradio 89 zu Ende. Chaosradio 90 gibt's am letzten Mittwoch im März. Vielen Dank, dass ihr hier wart, Jungs. Vielen Dank, dass ihr zugehört habt. Vielen Dank an die, die mitgemacht haben. Insbesondere noch diese zwei. Wie groß ist die Datei geworden?
Wie groß diese Datei ist, also sie ist echt riesig. Und es waren hier irgendwie zwischenzeitlich bis zu 20 Leute dran, die damit rumgehackt haben. Ich schau mal kurz, was dabei rausgekommen ist. Na ja, 20 Kilobyte mit vielen Beiträgen und so. Die Programmierer von dem Sub-Ether-Edith sind auch gerade dabei, da ein schönes, buntes HTML-Dokument draus zu machen, wo man wirklich sehen kann, wer wann wie wo was gemacht hat. Also wo auf jeden Fall klar wird, dass es ein kollaboratives Engagement war, was dazu beigetragen hat, um dieses Dokument als solches fertigzustellen. Wir brosten das dann natürlich.
Das war Chaosradio 89, es geht auf Fritz weiter mit dem Night Flight und Martin Petersdorf. Was wolltest du nur zu anderen?
Gibt's noch ein Freundlied?
Es gibt natürlich von Pete Townsend. Richtig Heat-Banging, wie wir Profis sagen.
Du mit deinen kurzen Haaren.
Okay.